In 2024, he endorsed Jill Stein. And you want me to give him
credit for kind of going after MAGA kind of hard when it's like
in vogue right now? What was he >> I'm saying since
the I'm saying since the new administration. The claim is I'm
pressing you and I'm treating you so horribly like you're like
oh my god. I'm being so mean. >> Dude, that's awesome.
Dude, I didn't expect Pisco to just totally out you like this.
Oh, you're so mean. You're so
Kathy, somebody's saying, you know, Kathy, a couple other people
are saying that apparently live and learn is >> Yeah, total
hodge death is happening. >> It's this idea that total
hutch death. Want to go back a little bit? >> Don't you
think that people
How many [__] views does that video have? 250,000
views. And he's telling his audience that Gavin Newsome vetoed
singlepayer in California. >> Here's the difference. Here's
Here's the >> Destructive. Here's the difference. Here
here's the difference. I think on net Kyle Kolinsky is a benefit
to our effort to stop Trump. >> Whether or not a particular
video I would think is bad doesn't really bear on that. >> I
I don't
let guy in guys
>> I mean does he understand that Kyle Kolinsky is like
the funniest one of these people that Kyle Kolinsky is the guy
actually like posting memes and people actually like and Kol
Kinsky like match in every way? >> Like I I don't understand
what he's thinking here.
Like I do believe there was a period of time where like basically
Destiny's subreddit was just purely reposting Kyle Klinsky because
they wanted somebody who wasn't a who represented their ideas.
Sorry. Uh e- rapist. My bad. My bad. Um
like he is just the next funniest. He's he's like the funniest.
>> Seen as a let's go with seen as a I think that's fine.
>> Yeah, we should be seen as a
>> I did used to say allegedly
tone, you know. So I should extend the same courtesy here. Seen
as seen as yes um what did what did Hassan say today procurer
procurer of I do think that's accurate
>> technically accurate >> technically accurate I
I mean I agree I think Kyle will come through in the end but
I I just I don't have a problem with what Hutch does at all I
I would never engage with the leftists they to me it's more about
like their lives suck and so they're looking for something to
blame a boogeyman like capitalism or whatever the establishment.
So, you're not going to get through to them unless you just put
some change in their pocket and give them something to look forward
to. Um,
but I I think the bigger picture for me is the almost 100 million
who didn't even vote in the election. I'd rather go after them.
They seem a lot easier to win over than somebody who's some ogre
boy weirdo who's got their heels dug in and, you know, just >> Dude,
Ogre Boy Ogre Boy slowly, he bought up all the real estate in
Hutch's head. He owns it all now and he's slowly buying up real
estate in IRI's head. You love to see it. Ogre boy continuing
to
Just continue to dude. How does this guy How does he have so
much >> crazy that these people like themselves get owned
by this like noseratu looking like lefty
rider with a tattoo? >> No, no, no. Hold on. It is crazy.
But Ogre Boy is awesome. Okay, let's make no mistake. Ogre Boy
is actually awesome. He just sits there working his job all
>> He He just sits there working his job and he's like
listening in his headphone and he like he listens for like 6
hours. He drops one tweet and these people lose their minds.
Their whole job is being an influencer. His job is like working
in a factory or some [__] Okay. He just does his
9 to5 and he like drops one tweet after listening to them for
like a little bit of the day and they lose their minds. He like
totally legit one,000th of the time. you you know you could just
they choose to like you know
focus on this guy so much I just don't understand it like if
you're going to focus on this guy I feel like the extent to which
you focus on him is like
you kind of like mock him right that's what that's what that's
how I would handle it personally if I was in a fight with boys
I would be I'd be very mocking and derisive towards him and then
probably move on >> uh but these people seem to uh not
just engage a little bit but spend like hours discussing with
their friends what he was saying, you know, and going over the
merits of it. >> This guy >> who spends like literally
a quarter of his um like break on us. He like he like literally
takes his 15-minute break. He's got to go to the bathroom. He's
got to take a he's got to smoke a cigarette and he's got five
minutes left to make a tweet and they're like, "You know what?
I'm going to spend eight hours on this >> I'm going to
spend eight hours on Ogre Boy today. It's embarrassing." Okay.
>> Wants to suck on Hassan's knob. You know what I mean?
>> All right. Point there. I I agree. We need to capitalize
on that. But I think what these lefties do is promote voter apathy
by saying both parties are the same. Like if you come out and
say, "Hey, I know this is awful and people are getting shot by
ICE." But remember Ferguson like ignoring Kyle doesn't do that.
But Kyle does not right now. This is on video. But it's like
like the idea that somehow you
peo taking the crazy dude. Sorry. I saw a nonfisten
another nonf meme coming out. Okay,
>> You do you do you like this guy cuz he's like the liberal
version of you? He's got the nose. He's got the He's skinny.
He's got the nose. >> I'm a liberal. I'm a liberal.
>> Ah, you're Hey, you're going pretty lefty. Let's be
real. You're going you're going pretty lefty.
>> You're going pretty lefty recently. No. >> What
position do I have that is like super lefty?
>> Okay. What position on Israel?
Um I just the general position on Israel that most liberals feel
like Israel is justified. That's the general liberal position
on Israel.
>> It's not the general how is it ideologically liberal?
I >> maybe maybe in America that's general liberal liberal
position >> but but you know even in in the UK and even
I think in Canada at this point really the >> the liberal
position is more Israel skeptical. No, it's more like a >> well
I've got the I've got the horseshoe position on Israel. That's
what I say.
>> You know, you know, I feel like you get it. No,
>> I Yeah, but I just don't have very extreme takes on
Israel really. I don't think I I just don't I I really don't.
>> I mean, I think it was like I think that's just recentism,
right? That this is an extreme take. the the thing that's becoming
more popular online and more popular in our circle specifically
is an extreme position on Israel or has been for the last like
50 years.
>> Yeah, but I'm like less, you know, I've gone less into
the anti-Israel than it seems like Chud has,
you know.
>> Yeah, but I mean, let's be real, Ch's been watching
a lot of Nick Fentes.
>> I watch I watch here and there. I I just don't think
I'm that crazy. I don't think I'm actually that >> that
far out. And all the positions I have on Israel are like, you
know, centered around not complying with international law. It's
not centered around, you know, some third worldist.
Oh, American imperialism.
Yeah, I don't care about American imperialism.
It's mostly just the I don't know having total technological
military dominance over a people and holding them there in that
state for years and years and years. I I don't know if I would
say it's about international law. I don't know the international
law. I'm I'm I'm uh sort of the Asminold kind of deal in this.
It's like I just see some people kind of getting tortured and
I'm like that's bad. Torturing people seems kind of bad. Blowing
up all their houses, blowing up all of their like infrastructure
seems kind of bad. I don't know, >> dude. I saw some scrolling
on Twitter earlier. Is it for real that ICE agents are crushing
detainees balls?
>> I've heard that. Is that the potato mc whiskey tweet?
Hold on. We find that pretty quick. I saw that because I'm a
potato mc whiskey enjoyer.
Whiskey like this. Oh, I added a U on
find this. It was right here. Oh god, never mind. I forgot this
guy tweets like a hundred times a day. Genocide.
Genocidal. Genocide.
Oh, it was here somewhere.
Dude, this guy tweets too much.
Dude, I just got a 4 hour ago tweet after scrolling this much.
That's crazy.
But yes, I had heard that that they are crushing the testicles.
Is this it? Yeah. Sexually abusing
males. His right front tooth broke and he said, "One officer
grabbed my testicles and firmly crushed them while another forced
his fingers deep into my
Dude, this is like um
this is like torture by kindergarteners. This is like the kind
of [__] kindergarters would do. stick their fingers
in your ears.
>> Legit like the most
>> It's very strange. Arrested development torturer. Yeah,
seems that way. Uh the big thing right now with this, I know
we're jumping all over the place. The big thing right now with
this is people are basically arguing about how much you can compare
this to the IDF.
Uh let me see. The recent Nick Fuentes tweet I think was on the
same topic because Hassan's been comparing this to the IDF. People
don't like it. Fuentes had a take today. I saw this when I was
sitting in line in a grocery store. Every leftist compares ICE
to the IDF. Who compares
ICE to the IDF? Also ideologically supports open borders, mass
migration, and white genocide. This agenda has always been promoted
by political organizations and billionaires that prop up the
left. Don't be scoped by left-wing garbage.
I don't know if I was talking to you, but I was saying this the
other day that I feel like Fuentes has picked the absolute worst
possible time to try and go mainstream with his takes and like
the shift is really awkward and is making him look mad at the
moment.
>> I think some of the stuff that's true, I haven't thought
about this one specifically. This could be a one that that catches
him that [__] with him. I'm trying to think of like
the ones where I thought because he's always had this thing where
he has to support the right-wing administration
while also being against Israel. Even though Trump during his
first term most pro-Israel president that's there's ever been,
right? That's always been like a a contradiction that's existed
in his ideology in the things he advocates for. And so like that's
sort of a thing he's always had to carry. I can't tell if that's
what this is or not
cuz I can't think of a lot of other things. The Epstein thing
I don't think is as big of a contradiction as people paint it
out to be to be honest. >> He's been defending [__]
teenagers for ages. Who gives a >> Yeah. Yeah. He literally
talked about wanting a 16-year-old war bride from Ukraine or
some [__] Like he like five years ago whenever that
invasion first started four years ago. Um so it's like not that
crazy.
But there are some takes where I do feel like he's trying to,
you know, split the baby where he can either go fully, you know,
against Israel, fully against like his his like anti-semitic
views or try to stick to the mainstream and not get like cut
off from people. And he's trying to split the baby and it just
ends up with weird takes sometimes. It's like the feeling I get.
>> Every leftist that compares ICE to the IDF also ideologically
supports open borders, mass migration, and white genocide. I'm
trying to think of somebody who's doing that other than Hassan.
Is he just talking about Hassan here? I can't think of somebody
else he's talking about here who's doing this comparison and
then I don't know if that comparison is even worth analyzing
or if it's just like these people have like a pet issue and they
bring things back to a pet issue
because it's like you know overt use of force um cracking down
on normal liberal rights like these are the things that they
see the IDF is being responsible for and so they're making the
natural conclusion the natural
um I don't know if there's like anything
and I guess he's is trying to say that like no no we're we're
like fashy we do support cracking down on on people's rights
on human rights we just don't want to do it for right so don't
get scoped into thinking that like this is bad just because the
did it we we actually just don't want we we like it we just don't
want to do we don't want Israel to do it I don't know I feel
like is that
>> is that a contradiction
thinking through this on the fly >> oh yeah I'm not sure
[laughter] >> lo poo is crashing out of Twitter right now
adding multip PCA is DMing me about this right now though and
he's saying I stomped on stalk
takes on this Nick
on on this guy Nick getting acceleratedly more post vacation
that's why he's too >> yeah CPCA has been DMing me a lot
I does CPS does CPCA have some reason he thinks this is like
um a contradiction >> I don't know maybe he's listening
>> he was just DMing me earlier I feel like he's listening
he just gave me what he thinks a contradiction is would be pretty
easy for him to just give me a contradiction. Hold on. I'll message
him. Contradiction.
He's messaging me. He's typing. He's typing. He's typing.
Where were we here? >> The executive branch putting a >> I
got to I got to stop. We got to stop looping out >> department
into
thinker is is on this right now. >> Contradiction about
what? Uh he says that this is like really contradictory with
Nick's past takes or something. So, I'm just wondering what he
thinks the contradiction is. He thinks Nick can't resolve this
with the rest of his positions. And I'm like sitting here in
my head, I'm like, I don't I don't know if this is a contradiction.
I haven't thought about it. Like I said, I saw this tweet while
I was in the grocery store today
chaos and incompetence.
State police is insane. It's just not all these same things.
And there's like all the like like Hutch said these
>> I should say beyond the original Zion Dawn contradiction
which has been his thing for as long as I can remember. It has
nothing to do with him going mainstream. big Google searches
of just how these things work immediately dispel them. And if
you're able to lie with basically impunity, like if people like
Hutch didn't call it out, then you do just drive this insane
like nothing's ever going to change. We just need to wait for
the revolution. We got to firebomb the Walmart and it never comes
and then fascists take power. Like it is >> You're pressing
me harder than you press Vanguard after they accuse David Pacman.
>> Oh my god.
>> Get over yourself. What the >> It's actually true,
bro. You are pressing me. >> Jesus Christ.
>> How am I pressing you? How am I >> I will say
even if that were true,
like when you're collabing with people, you don't just immediately
go for the throat or nobody will collab with you.
>> Case in point, unfortunately, um BC right now, >> um
[laughter] >> if you if you just go for people's throats
like instantly all the time, right? So you don't go like ultra
hard on clabs. might like kind of lay it out a little bit, but
you're trying to build like a relationship of some kind. If you
if the first if the first like interaction people have with you,
you're like immediately trying to like kill them, they will not
want to interact with you again.
It's like just social dynamics. So, I don't even know. I don't
know how much Pisco like let them go, but like you can't just
go in and just freak the out on these people.
>> I pressing you
are accusing me of of wasting my time and going after people
who use >> I'm asking a question >> and you're pressing
me harder than Vanguard when they accuse David
of being paid to celebrate genocide is what they
>> POV David Pacman. What's What's IPAC? Is this IPAC?
I've never heard of this before. Is it IPAC? I IPAC. What is
this >> I'm not
crazy to
[laughter] like I'm sorry there's probably you know I can't make
it he >> tried. Yeah, I can't say Pac-Man's paid for sure
but like that was totally
like that was so
>> genocide and you
[laughter] first of all
so first of all so first of all you're factually wrong. I did
contest that claim. Will you will you
>> hutch hutch hutch? Will you retract the
>> Uh, will you,
>> POV, you're just totally about to get knelt on, right?
He's like, if I get really emotional, maybe I won't get knelt
on, but uh, >> will you
touch Will you retract the claim? Will will you retract the claim
that I didn't contest the ideological connection between Chorus?
In fact, I brought up Chorus in the first instance. Will you
retract? Will you retract?
Will you take the moment? Will you take the moment right now
to retract your claim? >> I think we all expect that, don't
we? I feel like that's a totally normal thing to expect to be
able to press your friends like harder than you could press some
random person you're like trying to interact with as a networking
thing.
Like, yeah, you feel comfortable. You know their positions. You
feel comfortable like calling them out on >> That's like
a totally normal dynamic. I don't know that I didn't
the fact that there's an ideological imposition. >> You
said you're pressing me harder than you pressed them. >> How
am I pressing you? What are you >> Now you're doing administration.
I >> How am I pressing you? I'm asking >> you're
you're not pressing me here. You're not >> by by asking
you whether or not you think just elucidating the view that Kyle
Kolinsky is net bad for the Democrats. Just asking that question
is pressing you. >> Yeah. Well, you say like you say stuff
like Kyle Kolinsky he doesn't do that. What do you mean he doesn't
do that? In 2016, he he seen you saying 2016. He was Bernie your
bus. In 2020, he was on election night on Joe Rogan's podcast.
Joe Rogan asked him who he vote voted for. He said, "Nobody,
I don't vote for war criminals." Okay? After four years of Trump,
he said that in 2024, he endorsed Jill Stein. And you want me
to give him credit for kind of going after MAGA kind of hard
when it's like in vogue right now? What was he doing? >> I'm
saying I'm saying since the I'm saying since the new administration.
>> Why would endorsing Jill Stein prevent you from going
after MAGA? That's like a totally just a total mislead. He endorsed
Jill Stein and >> because you didn't suck off the Democratic
party the whole time. You need to literally be always on board
Democratic party no matter what they're doing, no matter what.
every given moment otherwise you're a traitor.
>> It's like >> also I hate purity testing. Also
I hate purity purity testing. >> The only response you
have to give there by the way is you understand that's exactly
how like MAGA got to where they are right. Oh these people are
evil so you can't criticize like the the party like if we're
going to be able to win you can't criticize the people who are
winning. It's like exactly how MAGA got to where it is. They
just kept saying like oh no the ends will justify the means.
Okay.
>> since so first of all, the claim is I'm oppressing you
and I'm treating you so horribly like you're like, "Oh my god,
I'm being so mean."
>> Hold on. No, no, don't be right back, dude. That's awesome,
[laughter]
>> dude. I didn't expect Pisco to just totally out you
like this. Oh, you're so mean. You're so mean.
Uh, fantastic. >> Why didn't you ask Why didn't you ask
them? Don't you think you're hurting the the Democratic party
by saying stuff >> the first topic of our entire
the first
>> the first topic was entirely monopolized by the quote
unquote elephant in the room about whether or not they're willing
to support and endorse Democrats. The end of the conversation
they say we are going to endorse the >> Yeah. after after
>> yeah they they have views of genocide >> bringing
up a murder and you know uh like Gavin Newsome babies or whatever
>> so which immediately I said I don't agree let's have
a conversation about that at a later time >> but I'm now
being mean to you I don't understand that
>> we went through the whole virtue signal I I went through
the whole virtue signal thing with the Vanguard >> you're
not hurting my feelings I truly I like these exchanges I don't
mind them and we can move on after this but like >> and
Pisco I do expect I love Hudge but just to be clear he's just
>> I do love Hudge like it seems like you're being more
you're diving more deeply into the ideology that Hutch is doing.
I um
I do love how every time Pisco every time somebody complains
about something Pisco does, he basically goes like, "What would
you rather have me do?" Like, "Here's what I did. Here's how
it went. What was wrong here?" And they're like, "I don't even
dude, I I don't have any problem with it." It's like, "Dude,
you're you're literally just laying out why you're mad. You're
just saying you're like saying the things they said that you're
upset about. So, what should I do different? And they're like,
I don't know, man. You do you. You just whatever, man. I'll back
off. It's so goofy.
Like, none of these people actually have like some ought to give
Pisco whenever they come to criticize. They just sort of like
soy out and then get and then go, "Man, Pisco is really mean,
man. This guy's like becoming a leftist or something. This guy's
becoming a socialist." And and I don't think you're being mean,
but >> give me a break. What are you talking about? And
I don't know your Vanguard thing, but it seems like you didn't
ask like even like follow-up questions or kind of like stay on
these topics with them. Is that kind of what you're saying, Hutch?
Is that it? >> You could have you could have gone >> You
could have gone harder.
>> Wait. So the the critique as I understand it, not that
Pisco agrees with it, just the one he raised is that like Hutch
attacking the lefties as like negative expected value, but he
in with regard to Democrats winning. But >> I I didn't
even assert that. I'm just wondering whether or not he agrees
with the assert. I'm like,
>> I'm [laughter] like, this is the So, we're having a
I think I don't think he crashed out." Okay, cool. I think >> they
did that. >> Yeah, something's happening. Yeah. Um the
I'm I was just there was a topic that was going to be introduced
about lefties and about Hassan. And I'm like, "This is the accusation.
I want to hear what you have to respond." And then Hutch said,
"I actually think it would be better off for Democrats if these
people weren't like influenced and stuff." That's something I
disagree with. Yeah. >> And I'm just disagreeing with it
as IRI is. And I just don't think that that is like pressing
Hutch in a way that I like didn't press Vanguard. I just think
I'm just like I don't agree. And I and I certainly said I don't
agree with Vanguard with stuff they said. >> I listen I'll
be fair and I'll I'll say cuz I told my chat I was like listen
you're not always going to take the same tone. Sometimes if you're
having some conversations on some platforms it makes sense to
take a different tone. And so like I really was balancing that.
Like I understand that that's probably what you were doing in
that spot. And so maybe there's value there. But there was another
part of me too that watched that conversation and there were
a few moments where I would have pushed back like way [__]
harder. Like the fact that they accused David Pacman of being
paid to celebrate genocide and then you actually to your credit
you actually said wait hold on and you called him out on that
and then he immediately 180ed that Gavin idiot. Wait what?
There's like one point there where I really thought you should
push back. And to your credit you pushed back and then they 180ed.
The [__] is THIS GUY SAYING?
WHO watches this person?
I need to know what kind of human beings watch this person or
like this is a guy I should get political takes from. This is
a guy I should listen to. Pisco is literally not even talking
and winning the debate. Hey, you should push back harder here.
But when you push back on the exact thing I'm talking about,
well uh uh when you push back on it, they 180 and like I guess
what are you telling us about how awesome Pisco is? Are you trying
to like argue that Pisco is being mean to you while saying how
awesome he is? very confusing. >> Fans should be in reeducation
camps. Can we be real? >> Is that Does anyone disagree
with that?
>> Um, that implies they could be rehabilitated and I'm
just not true. >> I'm just not convinced. I'm just not
>> Idiot immediately 180 and said I didn't say that
5 seconds before. >> Well, I think Yeah, I think I think
that was a weak claim. >> I'm just asking you like who
do you think is who do you think is doing more damage to Democratic
party prospects? me for focusing on lefties that I think are
way out of their like completely untethered from reality and
their quote unquote like criticisms of Democrats. It's not a
crit criticism to say that Josh Shapiro
covered up a murder. >> I don't think you're doing much
damage at all, Hutch. >> That is smearing a de a Democratic
party uh who >> I don't think you're doing if you're asking
my opinion, Hutch, I don't think you're doing much damage at
all. I think if any the only criticism that that maybe could
be levied at you is like an opportunity cost of like what um
is a better use of your time, but I don't think you're doing
any damage. >> It's it's >> I think Yeah, go ahead.
>> I think you give them too much credit, man. Like these
people don't have that much influence, man. I'm telling you,
it's to you might maybe disagree with me, but like the Vanguard
boys and Kyle Kolinsky are not determining the election, man.
>> Kyle Kolinsky gets like 40 million views on it. [__]
on Trump. [__] on
Kyle Klinsky does everything. By the way, Kyle Klinsky on everybody.
Like, yeah, Kyle Klinsky I I think IRI might be actually have
like a even dumber take than Hutch here, which is Kyle Klinsky
doesn't matter. It's like I think Democrats have Democrats should
have been educated on the idea that um actually like old institutions,
old political institutions are what matters. Don't listen to
any of these people on YouTube. I feel like they should understand
that that's
Like you want Kyle Klinsky to be a part of your coalition or
part of your party. He's one of the biggest influencers out there
right now. He gets he posts like he posts like eight YouTube
videos a day that all get like 300,000 views. Kyle Klinski is
popping the off right now.
I just I don't get why you would Hold on. Secular talk. Let me
look. Maybe I'm overestimating slightly. 200,000 maybe we say
like let's take a look now. This is 1 hour ago. 1 hour ago. These
are 30,000 each. 2 hours ago 16 18 17. Let's go to what? Once
we get to a day ago, what do we get? 430, 200, 96, 379, 186,
126, 71, 101, 102, sorry, 600. Like he's he's putting out tons
of videos a day and they're like popping off all the
Sorry, these are all within 5 hours. He put out all these videos
within 5 hours or something. These numbers are low, but that's
cuz he put them all at this all out at the same time,
right? So, I don't know. I don't know why you'd argue Kyle Kolinsky
doesn't matter. It seems like a goofy position. >> Spotlight
putting a spotlight on on Trump's like horrible. And this is
one of the reasons why like like >> I just told you that
Kolinsky told his audience last week that Gavin Newsome vetoed
singlepayer in California. >> I just almost any time almost
any time he talks about Democrats, it's in a negative context.
Almost any time. Bro, >> he he and Crystal did endorse
Jill Stein in May of 2024, which is I I didn't know this and
I I guess I retract my statement of I don't think would do that.
That's
>> Wait, he he endorsed Jill Stein, but I wasn't this for
something else? I'm trying to think of like they endorsed Jill
Stein and then I think for some reason I want to say he was he
had endorsed Biden by the time they got there if I remember correctly.
Am I crazy?
I could have sworn that he endorsed Biden by the time the election
was coming around,
right? Am I I don't think I'm I don't think I'm insane on this.
I'm almost positive, right?
Cuz I could have sworn we watched this already and we saw that
he did endorse Jill Stein, but then by the time the election's
rolling around, he goes and says, "Go over to >> insane
that they make that up." He does it every time. And so I'm sorry.
I don't believe him when he says he'll support the nominee if
it's Newsome. No, he's not. He's going to shift the p he's going to
shift the goal post and be like, "You know what? It's no longer
Trump, so the stakes aren't as high. That's what he's going to
do. It's so
>> Yeah. So, like I am totally Go ahead.
>> Well, I just say I think these third party voters, they're
never going to vote for Democrats. Same thing with on the right,
they have these libertarian weirdos that will never vote for
Republicans either.
>> That's all I was think.
Yeah, sure. This is somewhat a different topic. and the obligation
to like actually fight the lefties on policy issues like like
I like when I talk to more people it's almost always like it's
almost always about my issues with the actual policies uh instead
of like just trying to get them to vote for Democrats even though
even though maybe I should be getting them to vote for Democrats
>> constantly I'm constantly fighting on policy with these
people >> is there like is there a non-fighting
>> seems like he pretty explicitly
okay. I see. So, he endorsed Jill Stein and then he said if you
live in a swing state, you should vote to block
I see.
So, with the caveat that if you're in a swing state, you should
vote to block Republicans, he said go and vote for Jill Stein.
So, with the caveat of like, hey, if you live somewhere where
it matters, don't vote for Jill Stein. Okay? like that we could
also like spend our time like this person brings up an interesting
question like if we look at the things that we probably agree
with like you liked mom Donnie you endorsed mom Donnie and it's
like is there some of this stuff where we're not capitulating
to their you know I'm holding my vote out for a concession but
we're like hey is there
generational Hassan tweet just dropped what is this what is this
what is this
hold on oh dude Poo was crashing out again wasn't he dude I told
you I told
I told you that there's no way that this Puyos guy that he's
going to have to go like full straight up to make up for like
the lack of the the total robbing of masculinity that Hassan
did to him for him like that. Like he he would just have to go
totally crazy. He has no other option,
right? Check the Puyo's timeline. Oh boy, dude. He had he had
to go crazy. He had no other option. Okay, hold on. Let's see.
We start right about here.
Here. Okay.
Democrat. I'm the leading topic. The way you talk about me, hood
genius.
Okay,
you're a bro. You lied on my name like weirdo for virtual Twitter
likes. Go back to begging me for dollars on Cash App and saying
I'm your goat and you love me. Go lick my boot, [__]
Hold on. I get 70 $67. Do you have cash app? Yo, loss. Just letting
you know you're banned in Minnesota and if I see you, you will
be annihilated to a bitter end. I'm joking, by the way. Love
you,
Okay, I don't I don't get it. Okay. Legend of W. Uh, wait.
I've seen this guy before. Okay.
You're a spineless bot. There were six men on top of one man.
Dearmed him and still shot him. Stop lying to yourself and stop
bootlicking. You're such a phony obese.
Talking about spineless. You cheated on your wife, you fat loser.
Go yourself. Fake as trying to act cool with me. Then the second
you see weirdos dog piling, you try to hop on the bandwagon.
You're a [__] Wow, crazy. Yo, at Hassan the Hun waited
for the right second to trick his incel community as revenge
for my dog shock collar tweets.
He's he's always got an agenda. Nothing you say about me will
convince the real ones. You freak. You abuse your dog and you're
a liar.
Okay. And then he goes after and then he goes after Anthony Fentano.
And then he goes after Lwig. And then he's still going after
Hassan cuz Hassan responds. The only dog I put the shot collar
on was you yesterday when you deleted those tweets about ICE
and cried like a [__]
O
dude. Dude. Oh, glad you actually went back on your insanely
stupid statements about ICE and deleted them. I don't care about
the dog accusations. I'm a political commentator. Hope this helps.
Was this Hassan got his reply hidden on this? No way, right?
No way that he hid the reply on this. He hid the reply on this
one. Oh boy.
Oh boy. That's not
>> dude. Hassan just stacks W's, man. It's
>> And he sucks too a lot of the time. It's like, you know,
I watch >> He's like actually stacking W's now, which is
crazy, dude. Did you [clears throat] watch his segment on Los
Pooos doing the accent, like hitting him with the Guido accent
and mocking the out of him the whole time? >> I haven't,
>> dude. No, it was it was awesome. It was actually awesome.
Not in like a Oh, he's awesome cuz he's like Mr. Magoo and people
keep [__] up to go after him. Like awesome as in
like this was a hilarious segment. Hold on.
Let me see if I can find this.
It's on Twitch. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I got a time stamp on one of
these. It was so funny. Rain sent me the time stamp.
He's still doing it right now. O,
dude. It was actually hilarious. And
give me this VOD. Hello, Twitch. Are you okay? Is Twitch okay?
Can I not click through this VOD or >> insane order? But
how does it get in
>> Hold on. Let me find the lost PO stuff. >> even
crazier.
>> Just know all I meant is I don't want no more violence.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on. >> The new tweet from
Lost. I'm sorry for take it as I like Ice. All I meant was trying
to warn people I care about Ice.
They've murdered multiple people. The whole thing is dangerous.
I'm sorry for tweeting something that could have been misinterpreted
as me defending ICE. And I apologize for that because that is
not the case today. I've been made aware of illegal raising without
warrants and all of that. Oh, also guys, if you're watching on
Twitch, we're going to head over to Kick for the rest of the
stream. Okay? Head over to Kick. Head over to Kick for the rest
of the stream. I'll see you guys over there. Okay?
Kick.com/jok.
See you there in just a little bit. Hold on. Hold on. I don't
agree with anything they're doing, especially not following the
Constitution, but we witnessed multiple people get. So, my thought
was don't even go near him. I don't mean don't protest or stand
for what's right. I just don't I just mean literally it's just
a dangerous scenario. By tomorrow, if they yell at him a little
bit more, he's going to literally assume the position that, you
know, he's he's going out there to hunt ICE agents. Okay?
Like, if you keep stressing him further, he's going to be like,
"I'm going out. I'm a mauist now." Hey, I'm going to go and hunt
ICE agents in Florida.
Woke is back, baby.
Oh, I don't know. I don't know what I was doing, bro. Actually
took your advice, sat down, and read [__] I mean,
>> this guy still sucks.
>> No, it's good. Uh, he pulls up clips after he totally
buck broke this guy. He like actually buck broke Lost Poo or
whatever. And that I'm sorry
earlier
>> You will be brainwashed. Me, America's son. Ha, that
will be a challenge.
>> You bet.
>> Our enemies are all those in league with imperialism.
The bureaucrat. >> This actually unfolded over time, by
the way. Like, this guy literally was like, I like I think you
should fight back against I he dude, he totally got buck broken.
It was awesome. Where are we going from here?
This Yo, Hassan, waited for the right. Yeah. Okay. Where's the
quote tweet? Where's the quote tweet at? There it is.
And then loss what replies. I think he quote tweets back. Yeah,
there we go. You abuse your dog. You're a piece of Keep live
tweeting on your stream to your bots, loser.
I don't know. Uh he's Hassan's like actually winning now. He
is fighting against like a complete
but he is actually winning now. Uh new Hassan tweet. Let's check
it out real quick. Quote tweeted him again.
Hassan's reversing the the dog shocking stuff. He's reversing
it. Okay. Starting to use it for his own good now.
That's crazy. That's just wild, man.
Oh boy. Okay. More of this.
Listen, it's like shocking because for a while it was just, you
know, everybody up around him all the time consistently. But
he's actually gotten some some funny stuff of his own out recently.
You love to see it.
Oh, don't worry. We'll get we'll get to that stuff. I've got
all of that stuff ready to go. We will get to that stuff. The
the botting, the calling for like stalking Hassan.
We'll get to that. We will get to that. And As with Gold shockingly
backing
do you see that? You saw that clip? Yeah, you referenced it.
The throwaway
Dude, I I still don't know. Do we have that on O 2000 yet? O
20,000. Surely won't be posting that. PI will not be will not
be getting that one. >> It's like literally
I don't get how
like that that to me I defended this guy when people are like
oh he's just like a Destiny account or whatever. He's just like
Pro Destiny propaganda or something. I'm like no no there's no
way that's not true. And then he just takes like the the biggest
drama and totally squashes it.
You say pear
isn't every time defeats enemy.
>> Uh uh every time Assan defeats one of his enemies, Kai
experiences the quickening. I don't even know what that means,
but thank you very much for the donation. Reuben Ruben, thank
you. Appreciate it. I don't The quickening. I I lost it. I don't
know what that's a reference to. It's clearly a reference to
something.
I missed it, man. A barely posted about the techone. Yeah, I
don't get why. I actually don't understand why why it's like
mostly been missing. Oh, we did have this one. Hold on. This
needs to go into one of my things here. There was an asthmold
response to some of it here.
It is pretty crazy that he has not been posting about it. He
didn't even want to post the misk stuff.
It was crazy. Like, you're just a you're a drama Twitter. Like,
I don't I don't know how you make that call. >> Some portion
that we can bleed off of the Kyle Kolinskys or the Hassan voters
where we say, "Oh, you know what? That's a good idea. let's get
some like Medicare reforms or let's do the XYZ and we don't have
to constantly be infighting but we can still bleed off the ones
who are like otherwise would just be like I'm not voting they're
not doing anything I want. Is that is that even something we
can focus on? I >> I don't think there's a passive way
to engage with a like Hassan [__] a couple days ago
was interviewed by I don't even know some like pro-Assad
like Syrian like news thing or whatever. Uh
>> okay. Are we worried about
>> Does wait does he realize Assad's not in power? Does
he know that Assad is no longer in power in the state of Syria?
He knows that, right?
He knows that like Assad's sitting in Moscow right now. Surely
he wouldn't bring this up without knowing that. >> And
they asked him about I don't know what they >> Hold on.
One more donation. >> Reuben donated $3. No, I've never
seen >> He said straight up like, "Did >> you see
that one um
article that claimed that Assad plays like a bunch of play for
Dota or whatever the
>> No, that's funny.
I've never seen that before." >> Yeah, there was that funny
article about what he's been doing in Moscow that said he was
like playing loads of games on
>> That would be hilarious. I've not seen that. Your mic,
you're sliding in and out, just so you know, by the And they
asked him about >> I don't know what they asked him about
but he said straight up like you know a lot of people think that
Democrats are opposed to police brutality but uh you know Ferguson
happened when Obama was president which is a statement that is
so meaningless >> that it insults my intelligence. It happened
when Obama was president. What the does that have to do with
Barack Obama? That was a issue of the local police department.
And do you know what the Obama administration did? Eric Holder
and the DOJ at the time investigated the Ferguson Police Department
and they forced a consent decree enforced by a judge to implement
reforms at that police department. And do you know what the Trump
administration did when they murdered two people in Min Minneapolis?
They said the people were terrorists and ICE agents. You have
immunity. Go nuts. And Hassan's out here saying like, you know,
a lot of people dem Democrats are different on uh ICE. >> No,
no, wait. I agree with idiotics. >> Didn't I bring that
up in the Vanguard conversation? I'm pretty sure I brought that
up or thing. I didn't get through the whole >> I think
it was near near the beginning. One of the first things I brought
up was the fact that he was doing this false equivalence
uh with with one of this interview. Like I get it. No, that's
stupid. It's wrong. And the false equivalence
is pathetic. I just like would distinguish someone like that
from Kyle Kolinsky. I think Kyle Kolinsky and and uh Vanguard,
they don't do the false equivalent. And it's not just me who
says that. Like if if my opinion is
>> classic Hutch, do we catch this one? >> [__]
And it's not just me who says that. Like if
>> Hold on. Hold on.
This guy's a this Pisco guy. Just say Pisco. You're a You don't
have to do the face saying to your audience that Pisco. [cough]
How about you just tell Pisco to his face that he's a [__]
for saying that? How about you just tell him directly? You don't
have to do the face. Hey, Pisco, you're face.
>> You really expect him to do that? >> You really
expect him to do that? >> No, I don't. I expect him to
be a coward and just make the faces. But I want to point it out
just in case people miss it, you know. >> Very annoying.
>> If if my opinion doesn't mean anything, Josiah also
says that. Uh do you think Josiah is wrong about that? >> Yeah,
I think you're both wrong. Wait, yeah, Pisco. I mean, just addressing
the the fact we just showed the tweet where he's endorsing the
Green Party in the year where >> I know in Yes. Yeah. Yes.
I agree. I that they had >> not a false equivalency if
if you're unwilling to endorse >> 100. No, the third party.
>> Wait, but is there something wrong with saying, "Oh,
go vote for Jill Stein if your state is like guaranteed if it's
like locked in. If you're in something like a swing state, vote
for the Democrats." Is that really Is that really the same thing,
guys? >> [__] And that's by the way this is
to the credit of the Vanguard over Kyle Kolinsky and Crystal
Ball in that moment that they have always been against the third
party gre have always thought it's stupid etc etc. >> That's
not true by the way. >> Why are you rolling your [__]
eyes? >> It's not true. That's not true. He was >> so
show me when when did the Vanguard
>> That's why we point out the facial expression so that
when Pisco watches these VODs cuz Pisco does watch a lot of drama
stuff. When he watches these VODs
>> that that's that's clearly not true. >> Not for
who they are but on those opinions. Hutch, come on. What's the
lie? You're saying
to believe that these guys lie like they >> What's the
lie? What's the lie, Hutch? Hey, identify the statement. That's
a >> Urgent. How How is it an urgent miskip update to say
that nothing's happening? Watching you back. Thank you. I I don't
even need the clip. Nothing's happening. I got it.
>> I don't think stuff, by the way, I don't think that
transcript's ever getting released. From what I understand,
I think stuff's gonna they're like filing to seal and given that
Teetone leaked a bunch of [__] already, I'm guessing
that filing to seal will be effective.
Like I'm guessing they will be able to file to seal there.
Uh hold on.
Where do I find this again? Let me look this up and see if there's
anything different there going on.
yeah. Last I saw, there's just an application for to seal the
records for this. I'm guessing if that goes through, then the
transcript won't be published.
I feel like probably there's already stuff out in the public
that Pikachu didn't want public
and so it's just going to be like inappropriate to go further
into it. I think
>> like the statement that they What is the statement that
is a lie? Hutch >> told you. I just told you. They said
they disavowed the third party [__] That doesn't
mean I'll never retweet someone who did that.
>> Wait, wait, wait. You you [laughter] don't just disengage.
That's some right now. Hang on. Don't just disengage with that
honest.
They have not
actor. So you can you can see that they have some lies in the
past. I'm not saying they've never lied. I'm just saying at this
moment you have not identified a false statement. Have you? when
they had the conversation. >> Have you identified one or
not? >> Have you identified a false statement or
>> You can act dishonestly. You can act.
What's the false statement? >> You can act dishonestly
without necessarily saying something that's dishonest. Does that
make sense? In the conversation you guys were having about the
Taylor Lauren article with Chorus, right, they repeated like
three
things that were totally debunked within one day of that story
being dropped. Okay? They could have made just a tiny bit of
effort to follow up on what people were. They claimed they repeated
the lie that chorus creators had to go through chorus to schedule
any interview with a politician. This was totally debunked within
24 hours. So,
um, no, it wasn't. It wasn't debunked at all. Hutch is just total.
It said in the contract that you have to go through them to to
you have to notify them. So, you have to go through them. you
have to notify them. It said that in the contract. The fact that
some people didn't uphold the contract, then went, I didn't I
didn't even follow the contract. That doesn't make a difference.
It was about what's in the contract. And you can just read the
language of the contract. >> So, it gets to a point where
if someone is so incurious,
>> by the way, Hutch got absolutely knelt on in every debate
he did about the chorus thing by everybody. He got totally embarrassed
by Dickers on a wick panel. Okay. Dickers dipped out of commentary
like drama >> and knelt on his neck with no previous experience
at all. No no backing in politics broadly. Dickers just went
and completely obliterated him. Okay.
Hutch has no room to speak on this. Oh, right. Fabian and Liberty.
I forgot Fab and Liberty talking about it, too. Dude, it he got
completely humiliated on the
Yeah, he apparently cried in Dicker's DMs and I think Dickers
offered him like another debate on it, didn't he?
>> Yeah. And I guess Hutch didn't abide. I just didn't
want it. >> I hate this disgusting
rat, dude. I truly like this guy is such a subhuman. >> I
was cuz I wanted to talk to Hutch, but he blocked me and ran.
I couldn't I literally couldn't talk to the guy.
I would have loved to talk to him about it because I feel like
Dickers
kind of had just seen my segments on it is how I felt. Okay.
I was like very frustrated. H won't talk to me. Such
>> Yeah. I'm not I'm not a fan. Okay. >> If someone
is like not willing to make the the tiniest amount of effort
to to actually look into the things that they're covering and
all they're pushing is the same narrative. >> Didn't we
find Taylor was mostly correct? She's correct about the contracts.
She might not have been correct on the way worked in practicality.
Like in practicality, it might have been that nobody really followed
that contract. But the issue was what she was reporting on was
the contracts, what the contract stated, right? And people's
concerns about those
And so when they say, "Well, actually, we don't even do this."
It's like, "Okay, but what does your contract say? Publish the
contract." And they refuse. Like, well, I think we know which
I think we know how this goes, right? we they're going to tell
us well
I do think with chorus and I don't know if you remember this
queen but I think probably they weren't looking to enforce it
I think that language mo was mostly to get around um political
like um campaign finance laws to be like a nonpartisan pack right
they're like oh you have to you have to make sure like you notify
us so that we don't get into I guess maybe putting too much funding
behind certain dems or something like that
like I I think that's why they had those provisions in there
but I I don't think they necessarily wanted to like crack down
on people. I think they had to have them there to make sure that
they weren't going to do that.
Stream cutting out or is it just me? Let me know if it's just
you or not, DS or everybody, I guess.
Sorry, I was talking over you there. What' you say?
>> How true that is. I thought they would have said that.
>> I uh No, not banned on Twitch.
You don't know how true this is. I That is my impression. That's
what I like got out of it was was I think they >> I think
one if that was if that was the case one of these would have
said that they would have just been like
>> you know >> I think they tried to come out and
say that like like it's not that big a deal or something. >> But
I I think they do also want the networking opportunities. They
do want like those contacts going through them.
>> But I I think they want the contacts, but they also
if somebody messaged them and said like, "Hey, I want to set
this up." They would just be okay with it. or if they failed
to message them, I don't think they'd like enforce whatever negative
provisions are in the contract. Like that's the impression I
got. But that's again just my impression. And realistically,
when you're dealing with a company, you should deal with the
language of the contract. You shouldn't deal with um like what
you think would be the case cuz then they could just [__]
you over whenever they want
every day. I call that dishonesty. I don't think they're honest
actors. I don't know why we would spend even a second trying
to court these people.
>> Why? I think there's a lie.
What is that? [laughter]
>> Can you guys hear me? I'm just [laughter] testing it.
Can you guys hear me or not?
>> There is a lag. >> You're a little discombob.
But it's >> Hang on. I'm I'm going to refresh. One sec.
Okay. I
>> heated and right now one of the parties here. I do want
to say this. Uh we're having the demon on to have the talk about
this discussion next week. So, I'm sure we'll get more into it
and it'll get even more loud and crazy and annoying. Um, >> and
passing one, two, three.
>> you're back and >> Veim and >> Oh, and Ogre
Boy. Ogre Boy is coming on. >> Ogre Boy's coming on the
[laughter]
>> dude. Dude, look who they have to fight. Veem and Ogre
Boy. That's who That's who you're debating. Okay.
I mean, I'm sure I feel like they'd have other people on, right?
I just don't know who else there is.
>> Like, does I think there's a general problem like does
Mike from PA would anybody from Hassan Sphere like go on
>> Like, if they could get like Denims or Shondaanda Black,
I feel like they would, but I don't know if they can.
That would be my concern. That's why like Ogre Boy's base is
cuz he's he's just willing to be like a skitso barbarian on anybody's
stream. Like he'll go anywhere like
I want to buy them.
>> They would never have like a doxer on their stream.
Okay. None of them would ever They would never collab with like
a known doxer or somebody who's like trying to get people hurt
in real life. >> They'd never collaborate. Hutch and IR
specifically would never collaborate with somebody like that.
Be totally outside of their like um >> you know their their
own principles.
>> You really up. Yeah. Yeah. They never do that. [laughter]
>> It's going to be awesome. What a great show. You guys
should sub to the channel. Oh my god. >> But here, let's
hear from our guest. What is your thoughts on this on this back
and forth non? >> Listen, I I think this is why I like
talking about policy, okay? Because I think I think you can discount
a lot of the sort of uh both parties are the same and like the
weird narrative [__] especially if it is true of
these people like just never look into into stuff like if you
can uh convince them that like single player healthare. >> That's
really interesting. Nom fun. Thank you, Nom Fun. >> It's
a Brianna Woo position right there. I'm about policy proceeds
to discuss how awesome policy is without referencing >> this
guy.
>> He's killing them. Super great. Uh that like some of
these policies are just like kind of cringe. I think you can
make them a lot more comfortable voting for Democrats. And I
don't know if it's easier to convince them that these policies
are bad than it is to like convince them to vote for Democrats
because of the threat of Trump or whatever. Um >> I'll
be real though. Um I don't know how close Soy Pill and Non are.
Soy pill training nonf fun like gym streams. Okay, that'd go
hard for a little while. I think that would be really funny.
Okay,
I can't imagine anything would want to see less, but me personally,
I think that would go really hard. That would be hilarious. >> But
I think I think it need to be neb touch and he did go in on Ogrevore
about >> this guy's like rose rest. That's what he reminds
me of.
are you aware of like the the thirst post that Soy uh Soy pill
does? Are you aware of this? >> I'm aware. >> Okay.
Are you aware of like um I do I have no problem with um [__]
how do I do this without being a dick?
Oh, I don't have the links. Never mind. I don't have the links.
Listen, Hutch gets some comments from people. Okay, I won't go
into it yet.
>> not Hutch, sorry. Soy Pill gets some comments from people
on his thirst posts that are very >> of investment to pharmaceutical
companies revenues.
>> Well, I I want to wait real quick. I do have to say
because the the super chat has become elucidated to me with the
horizon effect [cough] trolley problems. It's this idea that
right now we we were just presented with a dichotomy. Either
Hutch does this or not or either Hutch goes super hard against
them or not. And the horizon effect is in in artificial intelligence
there's so many variables for it to look through. And so it can
only narrow this down to like a very small sector and then look
through these where if you keep trolley probleming and and narrowing
everything down, you get super tunnel visioned on these are the
only two options. and nononsus came in and said, "Well, what
if we, you know, have this like policy solution that actually
convinces people to come over with?" And so, like, yeah, you
can [__] on them, but you can also do this. I
I did not follow
I
swear to God, I just heard a channel directly through Soy Pill
and I feel like I want to go back and like try to listen to that
again. So, I don't I don't want to I don't want to put that on
him. I don't want to put that negative juju on him like that.
So, I actually am going to rewind and listen to everything he
said from the very
>> and I'm going to really pay attention.
>> Well, I mean, wait, I do have to say because the the
super chat has become elucidated to me. The horizon effect
>> the super chat has become elucidated to >> Oh,
trolley problems. It's this idea that right now we we were just
presented with a dichotomy. Either Hutch does this or not, or
either Hutch goes super hard against them or not. And the horizon
effect is in in artificial intelligence there's so many variables
for it to look through and so it can only narrow this down to
like a very small sector and then look through these where if
you keep trolley probleming and and narrowing everything down.
Okay so
hold on Wikipedia real quick real quick real quick. The horizon
effect also known as the horizon problem is a problem in artificial
intelligence whereby in many games the number of possible states
or positions is immense and computers can only feasibly search
or a small portion of them. Okay so this is like chess. The branching
factor in chess is something like 36, right? Every state, every
state below any given state has like um there's 36 different
branches you could take for all the different pieces or something
along those lines, right? Every piece where it could move, I
think it's something like 36. And by the time you get to all
of the states in chess, you have more states in the potential
game of chess, I think, than all atoms in the known universe.
I think it's something like that. Right? So it's saying the way
you actually handle this problem this this branching factor of
like well every time you consider a different variable you have
a different set of branches right every time you consider this
you you need to prune yeah alpha beta pruning you basically find
ways of deciding which trees you're not going to look at that's
like the solution to this so the horizon problem is just having
a really wide branching factor is there a picture of this god
it gives me a picture of go hold on there was a picture back
here really good move horizon you lose the game. So you can't
even see to the horizon, right? The horizon is blocked because
literally just trying to compute like one step forward is difficult.
>> That's not even it. It's something like this though.
I I think I've described it mostly mostly in a way I can understand
>> very small sector and then look through these where
if you keep trolley probleming and and narrowing everything down,
you get super tunnel visioned on these are the only two options.
and nonfunzes came in and said, "Well, what if we, you know,
have this like policy solution that actually convinces people
to come over with?" And so, like, yeah, you can on them, but
you can also do this and both of these things are going to be
aiding and and growing our party and getting both. So, yeah,
>> but these people are not serious about policy. Let's
just be clear. Like, if you ask them, you know, what would you
done? What would you have done in response to, let's say, like
the massive influx at the border? Like, put yourself in Biden's
shoes. Like, what what is your policy solution to that? I sh
you not. Every time I've asked that question, I've asked this
question so many times.
They they they say uh like um like cinemarxism for example, he's
this like um Twitch leftist. I had a conversation with him and
I asked him like how do you like vet people coming into the country
cuz you got to do that, right? He said his solution was to get
rid of all border patrol. He's a prison abolitionist and a police
abolitionist to get rid of all CBP, get rid of all ICE. And what
you do instead is you send a bunch of lawyers
to go physically stand at the border and then I guess migrants
stand in a single fire line and then you just hand them papers
and then they come into the country. That was literally what
he said. >> But but those are policy positions. They're
just not serious about getting it accomplished because it's obviously
way too absurd to to actually do it. Like it's the same stuff
of like you know the ACA and stuff like like they have a policy
position on healthcare. It's just that they don't have any mechanism.
They don't have any like serious thoughts about like how to actually
do what they want or like what the constraints were at the time
like when the ACA was passed, right? But they still have policy
positions that you could convince them are stupid. >> They
don't I don't think you can convince them that it's stupid. But
like they they don't they >> But you think you can convince
them to vote for Democrats like significantly? >> No. No.
I I I my whole thing is like I just try to like be aggressive
as possible with these people and you know make them look silly.
That's like kind of what my my whole thing is all about. >> Hey,
you and him feel the same way about people you disagree with.
What do you think about that? What did Queen go? Where does I
know what he said? >> Oh, uh I think he said something
like I just I don't even know about I just try to humiliate these
people as much as possible when they disagree basically. And
like you and him, you're like of one mind on that that like the
people
that too. Pisco Pisco agrees that too.
>> Yeah. But Pisco
Pisco agrees with that,
he wants to like humiliate them via the issue itself. I feel
like and I I don't know how you feel, but I feel like Hutch is
like willing to go and just like he's not going to argue why
the thing's bad. He's just going to like do a face into the camera
when they say that we >> I always do that first. I always
do that >> Okay. Well, yeah. Yeah, that's what I said.
I don't know how you feel about it, but I know Hutch is just
going to look to humiliate like by doing faces and just like
mocking them, right? Instead of instead of like trying to talk
through the issue.
>> Very very very interesting to me. That's how I >> That
will that will peel them off to vote for Democrats where they
otherwise >> Not them, but like hopefully people that watch
them, you know, audience. >> I get I get I get emails from
people all the time from like saying they used to watch this
or that person and you know, >> I'm doing those. I got
six emails that says Hutch was too aggressive. I'm a Hassan fanboy
now. >> I'm not [laughter] watching Hassan.
Like what I'm not what I'm not sure about is the is the prescription
because I'll give you an example. I had a conversation the other
day with Richard Hanania and Hanania [clears throat] voted for
Trump and he was saying like crazy like, "Oh, don't worry about
it. Like
RFK won't have any position of any authority and I wouldn't vote
for him if he if they made him a take secretary." I remember
sitting um in that election day uh stream and he's like, "Yeah,
there's no reason to think RFK will have he'll be sidelined and
marginalized and that kind of thing." And but that said, I had
him on and we spent all the time like assassing Trump and talking
about like abuses of of Trump like interventions and and hashing
that out. What is your prescription uh with respect to the conclusions
you're drawing, Hutch? Um, it's not that we don't interact with
these people, but is it that we don't have uh polite conversations
with them?
>> It depends. Like if you're if Pesco just did a very
subtle thing there.
Hutch now basically has to have like a very precise prescription
or he's the same as the leftist but with regards to how the Democrats
will deal with leftists, right? That Hutch was just mocking them
completely.
Oh, is Kick having issues? I could go live on Twitch if you guys
want. If Kick is having issues, I'll just go live on Twitch and
switch it back.
Can you guys even hear me? Hello in the audience. Chat's having
issues, too. Oh, boy. Okay. Well, hold on. It's good now. Well,
you guys keep saying it's good, but then it's going back to not
working again. You say it's good, but then it's like totally
not working and
cutting out sometimes. Okay.
All right.
All right. Um, I think what Pisco is doing here is super interesting
to me just because he's basically saying, "Hutch, you should
have a prescription for this." Right? It's funny that Hutch says,
"Well, these people aren't serious. They never have prescriptions.
They never have a policy they want to put into practice." And
then Pisco, well, he's getting criticized. People have like all
these ideological problems with him. And he's like, "Hey, could
you like give me a prescription on like how I should fix this?"
And they are silent. They have nothing. They have nothing at
all. Right? So I I think it's funny that Hutch's description
of why leftists suck perfectly fits why Pisco's upset with people
criticizing it. >> If your whole thing is constant Democratic
party the Democrats flowchart
and that's all you do then I I I think the best thing to do in
that spot for me and I'm not saying everybody has to do that
but for me is to match that energy and to just really I personally
think that the flowchart
is nuts. Like I think it's so thought terminating. I think it's
so stupid. And so I don't really make an effort to like hide
my contempt when people demonstrate that kind of logic. And if
if you find that in your experience that you attract more bees
with with uh that with honey and that works for you, great. But
um I I I think that that kind of rhetoric has just become so
common place in online lefty populist brain rot spaces for so
long. And I think there needs to be more people pushing back
again. I'm not saying you have to, but I'm I think there needs
to be more push back against it because I think it has done a
lot of >> I think like the 2016 Democratic primaries, that
event alone, and if you watch the Ryan Getty video, he gets into
this, but like I >> So again, Pisco said, "You you just
brought this up is a problem. What is the issue?" Hutch gives
an issue. Pisco says, "I talked about that, right?" And he's
like, "Well, yeah, and you kind of like pushed back and it fixed
everything." And then Hutch gives like another issue. Pisco says,
"Well, no, this is like crazy. I I totally handled this." Okay.
Yeah, sure. And then Hutch talks about how he hates how lefties
don't have any real solutions.
He's just he's like the he is the
the thing he's projected on to lefties. He is that thing when
it comes to criticizing what Pisco is doing, trying to reach
out to lefties. It's very ironic. Okay.
And I'm just he I he just did a whole bunch of nonsense that
basically just was like please he literally he did this before
when they had their conversation was a whole bunch of nonsense
into like please stop me Pisco. Yeah, I I know I I know I stepped
out of line, but please stop. Please stop. Please stop. Please
stop. Please stop. It's it's it's rough to watch. >> I've
been saying this for years. Like that event alone, I think, has
done so much damage in terms of the >> blast primary.
>> Yeah. The idea that Bernie Sanders was like robbed of
the nomination in both 2016 and 2020, I think is really damaging.
And I don't like people that that spread that lie. I think it's
destructive. I think it's harmful. I think people lose faith.
They literally think the the system is completely rigged against
them. And it's because they don't ever stop and ask themselves,
why did we lose that election? You know, why don't why don't
I why don't we do better with black voters? They don't ask that
question. They're just like this is rigged. Katie Porter, Cy
Bush, Jamal Bowman, you know, like down the line, that's their
whole thing. They will never win. They will never lose a primary
and then come after the fact and say, "Here's where I think our
campaign like didn't, you know, D." It's just like, oh, it was
just robbed. They think that the Democratic party, they think
that the moderate wing, the establishment wing, should hand them
power. Like, they just want to skip the step of convincing voters.
And they think they should like they think that Pete and Amy,
who were ideologically opposed to Bernie Sanders. They don't
agree with his ideal governance. They thought Biden was would
have been a better candidate and a better president, but they
think that Pete Namy should have stayed in the race to artificially
juice
uh Bernie's numbers to like help him on super
um I mean, no, they just think it's weird. I there's two ways
to look at that and they kind of mean the same thing, but like
there's another way of looking at that same problem, which is
it sure looks weird when you guys wait until the biggest day
of the primary to all drop out simultaneously endorse one guy,
right? Like it's it wasn't like you all competing to get your
ideas out there the best way you possibly could. It was like,
"Oh, if we let this guy snowball here, we might actually be."
That's like what happened, right?
Why is he talking about this? He's trying to talk about why lefties
don't work in the Democratic party. And he's using Bernie Sanders
as his example where everybody instead of he he's arguing instead
of looking at these structural issues with Bernie Sanders, people
refuse to do that and they just say Bernie was robbed. Bernie
was robbed. Bernie is robbed. But I do think a lot of people
are capable of looking at like the structural issues with Bernie
Sanders and why he couldn't win a primary against like Biden
or some other people, right? I think the fact that he did so
well is very impressive
to be honest with you. Um I think Bernie might have been able
to win in 2016 if Bernie had been willing to go full scorched
earth on the Democratic party in the way that Trump went full
scorch uh scorched earth
on the Republicans. I think Bernie could have won that 2016 primary.
I do. I think he could have actually, but it was the fact that
he was trying to be, you know, a team player, not burn the Democrats
in any way, you know, oh, Trump's the real problem. Trump's the
real problem, not focused on himself. Trump's like narcissism
is what helped him win the Republican primary. Bernie did not
do that. Bernie was very much like, we just have to stop this
other guy. And I think he got penalized for it. Also, the out
thing in Seattle or whatever where he let those two black women
steal the mic from him. That was cataclysmic. Okay. Too many
black men have watched black women step in and take the mic microphone
from them in their lives to vote for a guy who would let it happen
to them. Okay,
I'm just telling you.
Just telling you Tuesday. How do you explain that? Like what
world do you live in? Do you think that the moderates are just
going to give you power? No. Convince voters.
That's how you take the power. That's how you got to do it. >> Is
that like is that a descriptive claim or a prescriptive claim?
the way to get to power is XYZ. Um >> the way they want
to control >> or are you are you coming some kind of normative
assessment there? >> The way if if the Bernie populist
wing of the party is ever going to be in the driver's seat of
the party, it's going to be after they convince enough voters
to give them enough seats to have a majority in the party and
then they can have more influence to elect a house speaker. They
can have more influence to decide who is in the Democratic leadership.
But they don't I mean Hutch is just totally ignoring the fact
that that's not required. You don't need like a majority of the
party to do that. The Tea Party proved this conclusively.
I don't know. It's like so stupid. He's just like basically like,
"Oh, you need a majority opinion to have your opinion heard."
No, you don't. In fact, the way the Tea Party did this was they
went, "Hey, we're going to you over unless you listen to us.
Hey, we have a we have an important critical voting block for
you. We have like total like alignment with our voters. All right.
We're going to hold these seats. We are what you you need to
convince us that you could pass this legislation, that you should
pass this legislation,
and you're like one step away from the Democrats having that.
It's a totally legitimate thing to do the walk away stuff. It's
totally legitimate thing to do. That is
Like a converse of, oh, you need a you need to convince people
of things. Yeah, you need to convince the leftist not to work
against you. Not to say like, hey, work with us. We're going
to literally be a tyrannical minority in your party. You need
to convince them not to do that. You absolutely do. You could
easily have a group in the House where they get leftist seats
in like a bunch of these more blue states and then they just
say, "Hey, if you want to pass stuff, you have to like go through
us and it totally [__] the Republicans multiple times.
Why is he pretending it can't happen to the Democrats?"
I don't know. Like that is that is just how politics works, man.
>> They never do that.
>> Again, I just think they're talking past each other.
Like in that context, their claim is one that they they were
cheated out of whatever. And I don't agree with that claim, especially
not in 2020 for reasons. But but you just saying, well, the way
you win power is XYZ doesn't seem responsive to the to the claim
of we were and cheated out of it. It just seems to be like talking
about some sort of descriptive of of how one gets power as opposed
to whether or not what was done in a given context is like somehow
intolerable or bad. >> Well, the claim is not >> Yeah,
I understand what you're saying, but the but the claim is just
not true. the idea that it was rigged. I mean, Hillary Clinton
got three million more votes. And >> their claim is it's
unfair and you need to come with a claim as it's not unfair because
and not just the way you get power is XYZ. It's one is a normative
kind of like back and forth. It's not unfair versus it is fair
and the other is well this is descriptively how one gets power.
>> What up?
>> What's up? How's it going?
uh having a stroke watching this because points are being repeated
that I literally debated him on not that long ago [laughter]
on all of these exact same points. Yeah. And like he I I guess
it just means that he was literally convinced of absolutely none
of it. >> Cuz I've heard him bring up like uh I mean like
this is a guy to me who he's like these these like uh flowchart
leftists, they don't have nuance that's required. Anyway, I'm
going to explain the Green Lantern theory for the millionth time
to explain why Democrats can't actually do anything.
Okay, dude.
>> Well, wait. Can you explain the Green Lantern theory
now that you're here? I >> The Green Lantern theory of
politics. >> Go ahead. is the brain is is the invention
of Ezra Klene, everyone's favorite liberal,
uh, who criticizes people that expect things of, you know, their
elected officials, particularly Democrats, because we have a
bicamal legislation and checks and balances. So, all of the power
is not concentrated in the hands of the executive, which is true.
And sometimes people are like, "If only the president just pushed
a little bit more forward or if they just did this, they just
did that." And Ezra Klein's argument is it's not that simple.
There's a lot of coalitions and work that has to be done uh for
politicians and presidents especially and people in the executive
branch to get certain things done. But I do think that he overstates
the extent to which the executive is just paralyzed and uh Trump's
illegal actions notwithstanding. I would hope that people can
see oh the federal government is capable of doing a lot of and
very very quickly and very very efficiently if they feel like
doing it. Uh that should be evidently and abund abundantly obvious
uh given everything going on right now.
>> It should be abundantly cleared as recline that he's
wrong.
>> Uh yes
not going to happen I realize but it should be the case. Yeah.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Okay. Got it. Got it. Critical context.
How far were you were you wa you were watching this earlier.
How far did you get in it? Do you have any idea? >> Um
I saw like bits and pieces. So, wherever you are, I don't mind
jumping
>> All right, cool. >> Hour, I feel like you're just
not responding to them. I agree with you on 2020, especially
>> fair, unfair. I I I really don't give a fly about like
any of like those kind of descriptors. It's just the truth that
if the progressive populist wing is to ever be in a position
where they're the leadership of the party, it will be because
they convinced voters and not
Amy didn't deliberately stay. >> This argument coming from
this group of people. Are you kidding me? Like I think if if
I had to guess cuz I didn't see this part. Let me just guess.
Uh progressives believe that they are entitled to electoral wins.
Is that the
Yeah. That they don't have to convince people that just like
because, you know, they have popularity somewhere, they should
just get power and they should be handed the reigns of the party.
Yep. >> Okay. Wonderful. For one. For two, this group of
people saying the vote blue no matter who, no matter how terrible
the candidate is, no matter how uninspiring their campaign is,
vote for them anyway because you need to defeat it. To me, that
is like the same argument. No, they're owed your vote. >> Yes.
even though they haven't it's literally the same thing. The difference
is that they have managed to uh capture enough seats and like
you know have power already but you are the these people and
I largely myself argue for this as well like you should still
vote for them not not always because they've earned it but because
they have cross the threshold of being better than a Republican
which is a very low bar admittedly but it's still really important.
Uh but I don't understand like that grievance coming from either
side. Everybody has this feeling. No.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Like I don't understand how you could
say we need to cut these people out of the party because they're
uncommitted and then say it's because they expect things to be
handed to them and then also criticize them for being uncommitted.
Especially when it's on like a principled stance like the the
Israel thing.
Like I I get how you don't like that you think they should vote
against, you know, Trump, but I don't get how you could criticize
that stance when it is the same thing. Like, hey, you shouldn't
nobody's entitled to your vote. is his general like principle
he's he's trying to espouse here. >> It's like okay so
>> and leftists are like yeah exactly
>> not entitled to my vote so why should I vote for them?
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> To essentially hand it to Bernie.
>> Yeah. No Sophia, we all basically agree with this. But
the problem is is that Hutch agrees with this and then if you're
going to like lose a seat because you don't want to vote for
a leftist it
if you if you have a leftist who's going somewhere and they are
like doing well he'll still argue basically because of national
politics like you shouldn't even they shouldn't be run they should
be you know you should go with some nice liberal candidate
right I think he started to ease back on that a little bit but
in general it's the whole reason they're talking about cutting
off like this coalition cutting off lefties don't talk to lefties.
They seem to be talking about cutting off Kyle Kolinsky, which
to me is just totally insane. I don't know how you could be the
types who are like, "We need Joe Rogan. Joe Rogan's the most
important. Joe Rogan was somebody we needed to court right after
the 2024 election." They're like, "We needed to court Joe Rogan.
We shouldn't have pushed him out." And they're like, "Hey, Kyle
Kolinsky, the guy who's like one of the biggest, you know, liberal,
not even liberal, like lefty YouTubers, like anti-Trump YouTubers
that exists. We got to push him out, okay? He's like a leftist.
We got to push him out."
two words, purity testing.
>> Let's look in the rear view mirror instead of looking
forward and trying to oppose this administration. Let's look
for ways to shrink the tent and get rid of some of the most effective
and popular advocates right now currently that are willing to
meet the moment. Like I don't care if people want to criticize
people's past decisions and stuff like that, but it's weird to
use it to say that like a thing that they tweeted in 2024 is
that consequential and should outweigh their body of work now.
Especially when he's vote like Kyle Kolinsky, I know this cuz
I watch him has vocally said the resistance liberals were right.
I >> sorry, sorry, >> we're good. [laughter] The
resistance liberals are right that every single like they weren't
fear-mongering or whatever. Like there were different times where
I did not take the threat of the MAGA movement seriously enough
and we all need to come together to oppose this.
So you have Kyle literally giving PE like saying I was wrong.
I didn't take it seriously enough. You guys were right. I'm like
let's form a coalition. So to me he has satisfied all of the
prerequisites to be included in the 10. I don't understand what
the issue is. >> Yeah. And I would go beyond that to say
I do believe that Kyle Klinsky even though he did I think you're
talking about the endorsement of Joe Bid or sorry not Joe Biden
but um Jill Stein. Is that what you're talking about? >> Did
he do that?
>> Uh he apparently endorsed Jill Stein but he said obviously
if you're in a swing state you you shouldn't do that right? Oh,
well that's fine to me. If you do like if you advocate for it's
called like vote swapping where people you like if you're in
a swing state, you're going to vote for the Democratic candidate,
but then somebody in a blue state will vote for the third like
a third party or a green party candidate as like a protest vote,
but you can do it safely and that way you're not jeopard like
in the critical like rust belt swing states or whatever. You're
not basically giving up your vote to a spoiler.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And it's like, well, yeah,
I don't know. I I feel like that's that fixes everything to me
anyway. It's Yeah, fixes everything when you when you give that
caveat, which you did. So,
>> what are saying >> I'm going to I'm going to roll
it back >> is to ever be in a position where they're the
leadership of the party. It will be because they convinced voters
and not because Pete and Amy didn't deliberately stay in the
race to essentially hand it to Bernie.
I think what is saying is like if you're talking to these people
that are claiming fraud and rigging and unfair and you just say
that's not true that's not going to do anything. Maybe if you
like you know demonstrabably show the facts of it you'll bleed
the people off who are watching and say well it looks like that's
wrong but >> I this is why I would respond. And I would
be like it's not unfair in virtue of one of the expectations
in a primary contest is that candidates are able to tact uh strategically
and tactically withdraw and that's part of the rules of the game
and if you're working within the rules of the game. There's nothing
unfair about it in that sense and there's no there's never been
a norm against uh like dropping out for purposes of you know
making arrangements that's part of everyone's expectation. Therefore
it's not unfair. But you just saying, "Well, how you win power
is XYZ." It doesn't surprise me that it doesn't uh stick with
them because I don't feel it's like it's addressing their their
claim of unfairness. It just feels like it's a it's one as a
>> Oh yeah. >> When I debated him, >> for some
reason I thought here >> Oh, you're good. You're good.
When I debated him on this, this also came up like people being
asked Matt about uh you know the the call that Obama made so
that the candidates would coales around Biden. Is he allowed
to do that? Yes. That is his constitutional right to do it. there's
no rule in like the DNC or any primary process. Um I I think
it goes against the spirit of what's obviously intended with
a primary, right? I don't think like there are so many other
ways where past presidents abstain from weighing in on political
issues. If anything, a lot of them tend to basically politically
deactivate once they vacate the office. And so for Obama to step
in and put his thumb on the scale, yeah, he's like it's his right
to do that. No one's disputing that it's his right to do it.
But is anyone really surprised that people in the base feel kind
of because then it feels like oh well if there's going to be
all this backroom wheeling and dealing from party elites that
we're not even privy to and it comes down like a lot of it comes
down to that then that goes against the feeling that dem primary
voters are the ones really setting the agenda here and not just
party elites like steering the ship and then people kind of going
from
Well, it's yeah, like you get the impression when you run that
primary, it's like I think the thing that really upset people
and will probably upset people forever is that Liz Warren aligned
with Bernie Sanders like 99.9%.
And then she sort of made a deal to exit and people thought she
was getting a lot of it. I don't know what she got, you know,
years later. I have no idea what she got for doing it, but she
exited at the same time. Sorry, she didn't exit. She didn't exit
at the same time, right? She stuck around. >> Yeah, I'm
right on that. Right. She got voted out the opposite. >> She
like lost her seat.
>> She either lost her seat or she declined to to run for
re-election cuz she knew she was post because she criticized
uh Trump for January 6th.
>> And okay, I don't even know what like she got out of
that. So all these other people dropped out and instead of doing
the same thing on like her side, it seemed like she had some
sort of understanding that she was going to stay in and drain
votes from Bernie and then so she was bad and then everybody
else, you know, they coalesed around Biden. It's like if that
would have been fine I think to people if the race from the beginning
was Biden, Bernie and Warren. I think people would have been
okay with that. But it was the idea that >> I wanted Warren
to go away because Warren was the one who was splitting the progressive
vote and she wouldn't get the [__] out. >> Well,
I know that. But it's like at least that's the impression people
get of the race is it's like this this race between, you know,
the two progressives or whatever and then Biden and then Warren
could drop out or whatever. That's really not that big a deal.
It's like that you have all those other people in there and they're
like all throwing their hat in, but then it really was all along
what the leftist feared it was, which was, you know, the leftist
go the lefty people going up against the party elites. >> Like
that was people called them crazy when they said that's like
what the contest is. It's like the, you know, Bernie fighting
against the system. They're like, no, everybody's like getting
along here. It's all And then the second Bernie looks like he
might have a shot, it's like, oh wait, >> no you don't.
Oh, no you [laughter] don't. You brought this up. Uh, I listened
to a little bit right before I started streaming, but you said,
what was it? It had to do with this. Oh, that you said Bernie
could have won in 2016. I actually don't think so because he
didn't have a time to launch a serious campaign bid. He was intentional.
He actually encouraged Elizabeth Warren to run because he was
like, we just need somebody up on the stage to try to push Hillary.
We know Hillary's going to get the nominee, so you should run
and you should run to her left. That way she's pressured during
the primary process to commit to extract concess and like to
commit to more left and progressive uh positions extract concessions
from there and then you drop out eventually because it's probably
going to go to Hillary Clinton. So Warren declines to do that,
which is why it was snaky and as and stupid for her to imply
in 2020 that he was like there were uh like people leaking thanks
to to CNN like oh Bernie says a woman can't win, which made no
sense that he would say that given that he was literally encouraging
her to do that in 2016, but I digress. So he decides to hop into
the race just to be that counterweight to her, never expecting
to actually for it to be anything other than kind of just that
what I just outlined. But then he actually was like, "Oh, we
have a real camp like a chance at a real campaign." There was
a lot of grassroots energy, a surge of it actually. He didn't
even expect. He basically accepted the that he had won like either
Michigan or like Nevada or something like that in 2016 that like
the press like went up to his door and like knocked on his door
and he came out like pajamas like, "Oh, I didn't realize like
I won." So, it was too late for him to launch a serious bid.
The other thing was that the DNC still had these things called
superdelegates. So before a single primary vote was cast by any
voter uh in the process, they were saying like Hillary Clinton
has like 300 delegates and then would be like Sanders zero, Martino
Mi zero and it gives voters the impression like oh this is already
aware of the superdelegate issue. Yeah, I'm aware of it that
it's committed like seems committed. I think as soon as they
got called out on that a lot of places started looking at it
like they stopped doing the super delegate count as much or they'd
show it as like explicitly
>> right with the understanding. Yeah, >> I do think
it's weird for those to be displayed. Like I I think they shouldn't
be displayed until the
>> Well, they got rid of them entirely >> until the
convention. >> Oh, okay. Well, there you go. >> Uh
because voters back and they were like, "Oh, did it realize like
these people have this outsized amount of influence on the campaign?"
So, we get rid of the superdelegates only in 2020 for Obama to
come in and make that infamous phone call. And it's like, well,
what are we going to do? Outlaw phone calls? What? Like outlaw
like coalescing around like a candidate or whatever? Like I don't
know how you meaningfully curb this sort of behavior without
just kind of so having there be like social backlash to it because
you can't really regulate it. >> Yeah, you can't curb it.
I'd just say that it in my opinion I don't think that you can
convince people that it wasn't unfair. You just have to say like
yeah, we have like an ideology that conflicts with yours and
we don't think yours is popular enough to win and so if we have
to we will work against you. >> We'll work together for
as much as we can. We'll even commit to policies that we can
like agree on. But if it comes down to like, hey, we have like
an avowed Marxist or a former avowed Marxist who's like gonna
possibly win if we don't coales, we'll coalesce. >> I think
that's the reality. And I think people kind of there was like
an implication that that wasn't the case. That it was just going
to be open and everybody gets their shot and there's not going
to be collusion. But then when rubber meets the road, yeah, no,
we'll collude against you if we have to. >> Yeah. Know,
I think that's >> and like if he had gone harder on the
Democratic party in 2020, I think he would have won. There were
just too many times where he he just pulled back too many punches
and he really needed to go there and like you're already an adversary
to this cohort of people. That's how I saw it. So for Bernie
to like halfass it when it really came time for him to just kind
of take it like all or nothing dude felt like he hesitated and
it cost him. >> Yeah. Somebody said, "Oh, I get the impression
they think he's too far center." I don't think Bernie's too far
center. I think he's too far left >> in a popular race.
I think he's like further left than what you would ideally like
like it just in the sorry like the um the pime not the primary
god damn it the presidential election but I also think he just
wasn't committed to winning like he could have if he was just
committed to himself and like at any cost I'm going to win I
think he could have won in again like what you're telling me
sounds like we're speaking the same language although you're
saying something slightly different is that he wasn't fully committed
to winning in 2016. I just think he's never been fully committed
at all costs to winning and that's what him over. >> Yeah.
No, I agree. >> Yeah. Yeah. Bernie isn't presidential.
Well, thank God that we've having it we've had it proven to us
in spades that you don't have to be presidential at all to win
the presidency.
>> They people don't that's not what voters respect. They
respect a strong man. They respect somebody who is going to unapologetically,
unabashedly say, "This is my vision for the world. What's
>> Not somebody who is again like the the era of like civility
politics and like retail politicians. That's done. That's over
with for like the foreseeable future. You have people pushing
for John Stewart to be the like 2028 nominee.
>> And you know what? Like maybe maybe that's the you you
need like they ran their game show host. We got to run ours,
you know? That's going to be the thing that actually motivates
people.
>> It's not even like a game. It's literally just Trump
had the like showmanship to do that. And I don't even know that
he has like a coherent worldview. He was just like, "No, all
of you guys. You're all wrong." It just it worked. It just worked
on vibes.
>> The Dems could use somebody like that. >> and
he burst bubbles that I don't I think the Republican establishment
didn't realize that you could and not suffer electoral consequences.
Like he got up there and he was like, "Yeah, the Iraq war was
a mistake." And they were like, "That's not true." That he How
was he saying that? How? And then when it resonated with voters,
they were like, "Oh yeah, I guess that was a mistake. I guess
we can finally admit that."
It's like they drank their own Kool-Aid thinking that like all
of the that they have to maintain for like appearances, donors,
etc. It's like, yeah, that doesn't really matter to like a significant
amount of voters, especially when it's been overdetermined that
like those sorts of things are just like abysmal failures.
>> Yeah. I um I just want So, a bunch of people just got
really upset in the chat and I'm like looking for them. Dude,
nobody's saying Bernie should run now. Nobody's saying that.
Nobody's saying
Um, he was probably too old in 2020, but it like that's a hard
[laughter] thing. >> That was another thing that hurt mentally
less aged than Biden. >> I mean, he sounds like Bernie
sounds more put together than like Biden and Trump combined easily.
>> It's just got to it can't stay for that long. It it's
got to go at some point.
>> thank you, Vane. We'll maybe take a look at this in
a little bit. I'm hoping these people call in. Gedra, you call
in all the time. Gro, you're always in the Discord. I know you
got a mic. I know you got your set up. >> King Gedra, you
want to call in and say what your criticism is. >> I know.
I know you would never run away.
>> Progressives should propose new rules to avoid what
happened and moved on. Like, it's I don't see progressives bringing
this up. I see Hutch bringing it up repeatedly because his timeline
is showing him that people keep rehashing this. Apparently, the
only time I've ever rehashed it is because a liberal has brought
it up to me, not because uh like I've seen a progressive or somebody
on the left do it. >> Looking for He just said, "Answer
my question." That's not how this works. If you want to answer,
if you want to ask a question, hop on the stream. You're like
critical. You can hop on the stream. Do it. Do it. Hop on the
stream, bro.
We're waiting.
Waiting room. Waiting room. Waiting room. Hop in the waiting
room. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. I won't, by the way, I won't
argue with you. If you have a problem with what Strader was saying,
you just have that
But I'm excited, man, cuz mostly people are too scared to like
call me out.
Okay. Um, Gedra is too scared to participate. It seems like unlucky.
Too scared to participate in the VC, too scared to participate
in the chat should be the rule.
>> Help me out. >> Yeah, I'm just like, yeah, you
could come in and and chat. Not banned from the Discord, by the
He could hop in the waiting room whenever he wants. What was
Pisco's original question? Um, Pisco is looking for basically
they're going through the should we purity test out lefties?
Hutch has been on his project of like purity testing out lefty
people because he thinks they're like antithetical to the project
and Pisco's been saying well I want to talk to these people and
try to convince them. I do like that
um Hutch's best example of this was how or what he was criticizing
was the Vanguard I think.
>> Were arguing for Jill Stein or something. And then Bosch
talked to them and he convinced them. >> I've seen that
debate. I don't remember them saying that the third party was
the way to go, but maybe they did. I thought I just remember
them saying that you shouldn't bother voting for Biden and then
Vosch btfoed them and then they
>> Well, I just think it's I think it's very funny to me
that that basically just proves the concept of what Pisco is
doing. That exactly what Hutch said you can't do. Well, apparently
Hutch believe
did that. >> Yeah. So, >> and with Kaio Kolinsky,
who is and both of these people need to go away apparently.
>> Yeah, I just don't get it.
Anyway, all right. Uh, we continue on >> claiming one is
a descriptive one. >> I mean, I I just like the label fair
or unfair. It's like if Bernie Sanders had built a coalition
big enough to take on the moderate wing after they were inev
inevitably coalesed around the strongest moderate candidate,
then he would have he would he would have been in the driver's
seat. But he didn't do that. Is that fair or unfair? Like it's
it's it's >> that's their claim. Their claim is >> Yeah.
But it's your job as a candidate to that like that's the job.
If you want the job, you got to convince either plurality or
a majority of voters to give you that position. Nobody's going
to hand it to you. That's my point. Like I just the whole framing
just >> I agree, Hudge. They just don't apply this to the
general. They think it it ought to be handed to the Dem candidate
that makes it to the general though. But they like suddenly understand
that it has to be earned in the primary.
Yeah, exactly. >> It's like do they not realize this like
glaring contradiction? I I would love to hear what the explanation
is as to like why it's not a massive contradiction.
>> It is a massive contradiction. I think they're just
short-sighted in that they'll they'll say only the general applies
to like preventing Trump from being in office. That like, hey,
we'll do whatever in the primary, including trying to over your
candidates. We'll do whatever in the primaries and then once
it's in the general, then oh my god, it's all about Trump. You
got to vote for us cuz otherwise you're voting against Trump
or you're voting for
>> Yeah. I don't know.
They're trying to make their vote matter. That's what everybody's
doing. Yes. That's Yeah, I saw that watch you back. Thank you.
Um that's what everybody's trying to do, by the way. They're
trying to make their vote matter. That's literally how that's
why people vote in blocks. That's why you see so much block voting
in a two-party system of like, hey, we're collecting. We're collectively
bargaining with our voting power to get like concessions to us.
Why the system works the way it does
there. It's just apparently like lefties are a block you can't
possibly appeal to. Which I mean if you want to make that argument
and I think that is Hutch's argument at its core, which is not
a horrible argument to make that the block of lefties is not
big enough for what they demand in terms of what we lose in other
blocks. That's like his general argument. He just never really
works on proving it out. And by the way, kind of basically says
that you can't talk to lefties because they'll never move anyway.
You can't even move them over to your position, which I think
he also knows is categorically false, >> but then expects
their support.
which how do you square that circle?
>> Yeah, I don't know. Very interesting. >> This
drives me insane. Why? Why? Like I do Do you guys ever hear um
people that are like, "Well, we tried the moderate thing for
like the last like 50 years. Why Why don't Why doesn't the Democratic
party try the progressive thing?" How many times have you guys
heard this idiotic claim?
>> You think Do you think he hears his own straw man voice
and thinks like, "Hey, I know this is the straw man voice. Is
it possible I'm constructing a straw man? Is it possible? >> That's
not how this works.
In what universe are the you know the wing of the party that's
in power, they're going to be like, you know what, I'm just going
to hand you this. No, you do it by convincing voters. >> Okay,
but you're you're once again you're talking.
He said on Twitter today to Lykan in response to Lyken, this
is correct by the way, although he categorizes them as leftists,
which I think is a mistake, but a really like when you pull non-
voters and people that previously had voted for Joe Biden in
2020, why they sat out the 2024 election, Gaza is like consistently
one of the top issues. And so, and he was somebody who was like,
"We need to ignore the uncommitted movement. we can't have a
Palestinian speak of the DNC even though it it's a it's a Palestinian
Democrat. Somebody who already held elected office as a Democrat
was going to give a very like was or was submitting their willing
to submit their speech in advance and it was nothing like super
offensive or or radical or anything like that. It was like a
totally like reasonable concession to make to the uncommitted
movement that had garnered like several th like tens of thousands
of people to write it in in their primary race. and he said,
"Nope, they should not be included. They should be ignored. We
can win without them. We don't need them. There's room for anti-Trump
Republicans on the DNC stage. Not room for Democrats that are
going to be that are going to bring up Gaza that are going to
bring up Israel Palestine." Then he's even reiterating today
that he sat down and looked at the polling data and saw that
a lot of non- voters were uh like in large part demotivated from
voting because of Gaza. But then, and he's over here being like,
"You have to earn people's votes. They're not just going to give
it to you. You got to earn it." But he was doing everything in
his power to be like, "Ignore these people. Ignore them. We don't
need them. We don't need to earn their votes at all." >> And
now we're scolding them for costing the election, even though
it's not clear to me that that's even the case.
>> Well, I think the only I mean, I'd have to see. The
only place I think that's even remotely close
to being
like a possibility is got to be Michigan. And I remember I I
think I went and looked this up and I'm like, "Dude, are there
even enough like Muslim voters? Are there even enough Muslims
in Michigan to to swing it? I'm not sure. Hold on. Muslim." No,
no, no, no, no. Uh 2024 Michigan.
>> Well, Michigan that was like a deadly combination like
not just combo like of different circumstances as to what went
wrong there. So there's the largest ArabAmerican population that's
in that state for one. Obviously like Mina or Middle Eastern
and I think it's like I can't remember what it stands for but
uh they were obviously in opposition to the genocide critical
of Israel etc. They were not happy with Joe Biden's approach
to this. Uh Kla Harris's uh bringing out Bill Clinton to lecture
these voters on Judea and Samaria. That was her campaign strategy
and pitch to those voters. Wow. What a shock that it failed and
didn't land with them. Then you look at Trump and he was just
doing basic politician 101. Yeah, I'm going to get like there's
not going to be any new wars. Total lie, obviously. Uh I'm going
to end all of this and then the monkeys paw curled and they don't
realize that when he says I'm going to end it, he means I'm going
to accelerate the death so that we can just give Israel everything
they want just on a faster timeline. That's what he meant by
I'm going to end this soon. Uh but that worked for voters and
he got a non-inssignificant amount of uh Arab-American voters
even uh who used to vote Democrat because he just went out there
and reaffirmed what they wanted to hear even though he obviously
had no intention of uh making good on those promises or doing
it in a very specific way that they didn't realize that's what
he meant when he made that pitch. But the Harris campaign couldn't
put there there was not a single consultant around her that could
tell her, "Yeah, do that and you can actually make have some
ground here in in in Michigan."
>> Isn't the whole thing like I don't understand. How are
your ads not just like showing Trump Heights in the Yolan Heights?
Um showing Trump and BB hanging out, showing Jared Kushner, Trump's
son-in-law, being best friends with BB. Why don't you just attach
Trump's name to BB Netany and Yahoo in the state of Michigan?
Why why weren't they just running those ads the whole time? I
don't understand why they do anything else. I don't understand
why you a lot of the pro-Israel side >> by that point.
A lot of Democrats, and this is still the case, take Apac money
and Apac is like explicitly aligned with Republicans and MAGA
voters. Uh, and they themselves do not want to be openly critical
of Israel, the Israeli policy. Like they'll say they'll be openly
critical towards BB, but at the end of the day, the majority
of the Congress is showing up to watch BB give his stupid speech,
and they're going to stand up and give him a standing ovation
like every other Republican. >> Uh yeah, well, I'm lucky
they did want to appear pro-Israel, and they're starting to realize
that that was like not the best long-term plan, I think. But
I don't know. I guess as long as everybody's moving in lock step,
as long as the Republicans are more pro-Israel, it's probably
not a problem. I don't know. But yeah, I think I think suffice
to say in Michigan I I think Michigan's the only swing state
for the the Gaza issue. I don't know. Somebody linked a poll,
I doubt it could be that extreme. Here it is.
I feel like I doubt it could be that extreme. Even if people
say like, "Oh, I I didn't vote because of this." It's like I
wonder what the methodology is. Second, where's this 42XX
Middle East eye? When is this from? Is this just recent? This
this article 20th of January 2025. It's actually a full year
ago. Okay. Why Harris received 6 million fewer votes than Biden
found that 29% of Americans who voted for Biden in 2020 and didn't
vote for Harris in 2024 cited ending Israel's violence in Gaza
as their reason for withholding their vote.
I feel like there's no way that that's possibly true.
um just based on the like there's no way if that was really what
was happening that Democrats wouldn't have been slaughtered across
the board or
that
oh how do I even explain it? I just I feel like if this was true
>> Republicans almost as hard too like I just I don't think
this could really be
the reason. I I think it has to be like economic incumbent dis.
No, I think >> you have to remember that like people it
doesn't always even just come down to like what the opposition
candidate is pitching even if when you actually look at their
pitch they're promising to be even more barbaric in Israel and
and with respect to Israel Palestine people like a lot of voters
largely will look up see who's in charge and blame that party
and they will listen to and entertain
uh basically whatever pitch the other side is giving and what
the other side is giving in this case is uh they're doing it
wrong, I'd do it better. But they don't really get into the specifics,
even though the Republican policy is just going to be more of
the same, just more intense.
I'd have to look this up. I almost I feel like almost certainly
swing states and then this. So, this is
online sample 604 voters for a week. Uh online sample 47. [__]
I don't I literally don't care. No, I I think that's absolutely
for the inst Institute for Middle Eastern Understanding Policy
Project.
I feel like I already immediately I just see the numbers and
I'm like I don't think this is >> I thought what you pulled
up was Yuggov
>> Uh they ran it in collaboration with >> Yuggov.
They funded it through Yuggov. So, you could just say it's a
yug pull, but I I just feel like
I swear I just don't think this is
I'm sitting here and I'm like I I'm suspicious. I'd have to look
through this to see what you could draw conclusions on, but it
seems like online only polls I already am very suspicious of
and then >> Yeah, there's selection bias there for
>> it was just it's harder to conduct this these types
of polling this type of polling though because there were a lot
of articles saying, "Oh, no. It wasn't that that cost Biden the
election." That wasn't an issue or like it wasn't a major issue
at the end of the day. But what they did is look at exit polling
from people that voted to say these were the top issues of voters
of this year. And it's like we're trying to look at people who
didn't vote. So trying to reach those people is a more arduous
task. And I'm not surprised that they start online first because
I mean what what are they going to do? landlines
>> cuz then it just skews old.
>> I do. So it does skew old.
There's 70. No, 71% did not withhold for a different reason.
If you look at this, it's actually got the reasons laid out.
It was like um 29% ending Israel's violence in Gaza, economy,
Medicare, Social Security, immigration and border security. I
think this is insanely low that people who voted for Biden and
switched that it's only 11% immigration when to me that's by
far the biggest change between the two presidencies like economy
and immigration immigration being 11% that's like total to me.
>> Is this people that used to vote for Dems or is it like
non voters generally or like independents and Dems?
>> Um it's people who voted for Biden Biden 2020 voters.
So >> well that actually >> I think it's inherent.
No, that that doesn't surprise me cuz them voters you would expect
to be more like pro immigration and so you would I wouldn't expect
people that voted for Biden in 2020 to be like I can't vote for
Biden because he's too weak on the border as like their main
grievance. >> That's a independent thing for sure. Independents
were upset about that like
>> I maybe I think a lot of Dems were upset about border
security. Biden like objectively failed on the border and I think
everybody who copes about like oh well Republicans didn't want
to pass a bill that's just insane cope. Like obviously the executive
had the had the capability to shut down the border and he didn't
want to do it. >> No, he did it. >> I I think >> but
it was unconstitutional and it was challenged in federal court.
>> He waited. >> He waited until way way way later.
And how did >> Well, you said he didn't do it. I'm saying
he did do it, but then it was challenged. But I don't think he
should take action that he knows to be >> like his biggest
political liability. That's when he did it. >> And then
when he did it, his polling his polling increased.
>> Yeah. But I'm saying that like the problem was they
could point to the numbers and they've been complaining for months
and
and the numbers kept getting worse and worse and then he was
like, "I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't do it. Pass a bill.
Pass a bill. Pass a bill." And basically, I think the way that's
pitched to Americans is he absolutely just left the border open,
let America be raped in general, and then was like, "Oh, uh,
whoops. I guess I'll close it now. Also, we should pass a bill."
And it's like I Okay, that looked incredibly weak. That was really
>> You're You're triggering my chat. Someone put shut down
the border. When was the border open? What the [__]
is he talking about? Response. Go.
>> Shut down the border. As in um dropping what? I I think
you could just close the border, right? You just say we're closing
the border. I mean, obviously there illegal immigration, but
I think your chatter would know that the biggest cause of like
an influx of immigration was asylum seekers, right? So, you shut
that shut it down for asylum seekers. You pause people at the
border. >> Yeah, that's a title 42 thing, but that's unconstitutional.
But Biden knew it would be ruled unconstitutional. So I think
the reason why he was he didn't do it for a long time is because
he knew it would immediately be struck down. But to me at that
point like not only are you like most a lot of independents had
the assessment that you just had which is well too little too
late. And with Biden it was like he viewed it as obviously cuz
he knew I think he knew it was going to be unconstitutional too
much but too late. And then they ended up saying you can't do
it anyway
because then you can't shut down without like an emergency but
you can just declare an emergency of some kind, right? Like if
you actually have the political will to do it there are like
Trump did shut the border down again, did he not? Or asylum
>> Um I believe so, but he he like declares these like
states of emergency, but then all of those get challenged in
court and Democrats are actually far more likely to actually
respect when a federal court is like, "No, this is a or bogus
like pretext or whatever."
>> Sure. But then, yeah, that's just another thing where
like the strong man who actually has the political will is winning
on that issue like really hard.
now, I do agree. Jesus Christ, this guy's going off. Um, I do
agree with you though that like respecting law and stuff is important,
but unfortunately, it seems like there's just no way to
I don't know. I I I think that killed them. I think >> Well,
Josiah is like of your opinion. I don't think you guys have the
same opinion as far as like feelings on immigration, but he was
saying that like he supported Biden taking that action because
he felt it was important to respond to voters needs in that moment
and to stop Trump. And so he was like, well, he should at least
try it. Like yeah, did he know it was probably going to be deemed
unconstitutional, but like worth a shot and his polling improved.
So that was the correct move, but he should have done it earlier,
but to me, he shouldn't have taken that action. I think that
there like that's a whole other thing in and of itself like what
went wrong there. The issue is that like Democrats focused too
much on that bipartisan border bill like you're saying and it
was total capitulation to every single Republican demand and
all it did was make them want mass deportations on top of it.
So there was no need to do that. They were not going to vote
on it and Donald Trump pressured the Donald Trump and other Republican
elites pressured the uh party to withhold their vote on it so
that he could run on it as an issue. like Harris wasn't lying
when she said that that was >> I
I mean I I guess so. I just to me I just don't understand
personally how both parties I I don't understand how it was allowed
to like this asylum seeking loophole was allowed to stand for
as long as it did. It just seemed pretty I don't know. Oh, it's
>> what loophole.
>> The just the idea that like basically there's one screening
set of questions that everybody knew the answers to that would
get everybody into the country and you just let everybody in
and then you're like, "Okay, now the courts are way backed up
so they're just here." It's like literally people used to at
least have to try to cross a river. Some of them drowned. Now
they just show up and they like have the the multiple choice
laid out and they're just like, >> "No, they do that as
well. They're doing that as well to go take that test. That didn't
stop. the geographic [laughter and gasps] situ like reality on
the ground hasn't changed as people are willing to do it. To
me, the issue is not that we need to have like higher standards
or anything like that. It's that we just don't have the infrastructure
to deal with all of these uh asylum pleas that are being made.
>> Wait, but I also I also thought people were basically
pre-approved for asylum before they even got to the border because
of some app that existed. >> Um app not familiar with this.
I know that certain people from certain regions depending on
like the reason why you were fleeing or the area had like sometimes
an expedited process, but I'm not familiar with any like
uh loophole to the extent that you're talking about. >> But
I mean, you're talking to somebody who like
>> I I support like it's so literally No, it's so funny
to me that like Democrats are pro border like that's how they're
viewed or whatever because uh I actually am proop borders and
I'm like no the they're not. They're not pro open borders by
any means and they are uh a lot of them like if you listen to
how even like Pelosi sounded on immigration just like 20 30 years
ago she sounds like a Republican today. They have moved significantly
on the issue but that still doesn't mean that overall they're
not h >> listen to Bernie Sanders 10 years ago. I I don't
know how people who are like leftists, like actual leftists,
believe in open borders when he lays out the case for why that's
like silly, like pretty openly >> because he bases it on
these on these uh like he he's more correct when it comes to
how like global free trade can end up causing like short-term
economic stress for people as like uh jobs are exported overseas
or whatever. But I think some of the data that he has informing
his beliefs and policy prescriptions surrounding how it like
depresses wages um are it's either like highly concentrated to
particular sectors or in very local areas, but he kind of overstates
the extent to which it ends up being like a blanket thing. Like
Bernie goes so far as to like praise he's been like praising
Trump on some of his immigration policy in the last year, not
even like 10 years ago, like >> Fundamentally different
issue, right? NAFTA is like a fundamentally different issue.
You talk about free trade But Bernie ties his immigration policy
into
>> Um, well, it's the same thing where people without an
education, like if you just want somebody who can do tasks for
you, you just want gophers, then you don't really need them to
be able to speak English, and you especially don't need them
to earn a minimum wage. And so obviously there's a certain group
of people who do get their wages depressed massively by open
immigration
>> um in certain sectors again because a lot of these these
uh migrant workers do jobs that Americans don't want to do. Like
for example factory farms like Tyson is literally at the point
where they're offering $30 an hour for Americans to work in factory
farms because they can't get people Americans to do these jobs.
>> Yeah. Exactly. that like they're they're really rough
jobs and the market isn't there, right? Like they they literally
have an industry that doesn't exist under the law, like legally
can't exist and so they have to operate outside of the law.
>> It might be one of those things where like um yes, I
agree with you. Um it might be one of those things though as
far as like how it drives down wages is that like when you look
at the net effect. It is either null or it's very very small.
But the variance between each sector can like be you can have
like a lot like certain sectors it depresses them significantly.
Others it doesn't really impact them that much because American
workers aren't competing. It just really really depends on like
what you're talking about. Um but like a whole other aspect of
immigration that's like they don't talk
>> you think it's what I think in terms of the economy,
I think open borders would be a massive boon to the American
economy. Like overall, >> yes, that's why Ronald Reagan
wanted it. It's a neoliberal position. Also, >> it's literally
like Yeah. Like raw GDP wise, that would be the best thing. You
have the most immigration. You have the most like possible like
labor in terms of what you spend, >> right? And you max
out productivity. I just don't understand how you do that. And
also want social safety nets. Like if you're a leftist, you want
some kind of social safety net. That's totally insane to me to
advocate for open
>> Well, usually the like when Reagan was proposing open
borders, he was basically proposing kind of this like make it
easier for people to secure work visas, but it was not going
to extend to getting the all of the benefits of citizenship.
And right now, if you're an immigrant in this country, you pay
taxes, but you really don't get much out of it. So, they pay
into the system and
>> just for funsies, basically. So like like all there's
like so many misconceptions
do
>> I would say there's people say that and I do agree.
I think basically to me that should be like the check ICE does
in my opinion is like ICE should basically go and say okay we
can deport people who are illegally here who don't pay taxes
or are criminals. But if they both are not criminals and pay
taxes I feel like those people automatically should get bumped
down to the bottom of a list. Like if you could give me a social
insurance number or social security number that pays taxes and
it like I can confirm you pay taxes into it somehow. I feel like
those person those people should just be allowed to stay. I do
think people say that they all pay taxes. I don't think they
all pay taxes. I think if you getting paid in cash under the
table >> the ones that don't probably but they make so
little that they even if they were to do like to report their
income they wouldn't pay that much to begin with. But you're
probably right. But I think I shouldn't exist. So that's where
we diverge on that. [laughter]
>> it's a new It's a very new agency. It was only created
under uh George Bush. Second one, not the first.
>> I didn't even know that. >> And also the what
gets left out, that's what I was going to say, is like a lot
of the stats surrounding immigration is like high-skilled immigration
labor also makes it into those stats. And so, yeah, when we're
we're in a global economy, a lot more people are working remotely,
especially for white collar fields. So, you're now going to be
competing not only with other uh like workers in the United States,
you're also going to be competing with jobs that your company
is willing to outsource to uh Europe, India,
and like Mexico,
Canada, any number of places where they have high school labor
that can work remotely for your company.
Yeah, I think that's broadly how the immigration policy should
work in the United States is essentially it should just be um
if you hire people who are illegal, you have to manage paying
their taxes and you have to pay a premium on it. So that basically
like yeah, you can hire like Mexican workers who are going to
work for very little, but you're going to have to pay a premium
there to basically make up for the job you're possibly taking
away from a citizen. And then even for the higher skilled ones,
I think you shouldn't even be able to pay the average in a field.
you should just be able you should be paying like essentially
because the argument they always do this is what VC says is like
these are like 95th 99th percentile workers these are like the
Albert Einsteins we want these people it's like okay so you should
be forced to pay them like Albert Einstein right like I I think
you should just pay the difference to the government
and government makes a bunch of money it's like totally fine
but that'll never happen unfortunately
disgusting that'll never get proposed
that would never be lobbied for in any
anyway so yeah I don't know I don't know how we ended up here
but yeah my general position was open borders plus social safety
net doesn't make sense to me. I don't think it's >> my
general proposal is that open borders and social safety nets
do. >> Not with that attitude. It won't. I mean, yeah,
you basically have to change
change I don't know the wealth discrepancy overnight to make
it work. I just don't see how it works. But yeah, anyway, back
to this. We're we're back. Let's go. J got quieter. I leaned
away from my mic. I need to switch back to my like intimidated
directional mic is rough. No, >> you couldn't handle a
different opinion.
Uh, I think lots of people have differing opinion. I like arguing
about this stuff and nobody nobody in chat ever shows up to argue
anymore. I like say, "Hey, hop on the stream if you disagree
and they're just like, "No, I don't want to do that. No, I couldn't
do that." So, it's nice having somebody who will actually disagree
once in a while. Anyway, yeah, back to um
saying the same thing for the hundth time. >> Isn't how
one receives the power. It's like it would be wise to do X strategy.
It would be wise for us to do to choose this. And what you're
saying is, well, haha, you can't win. This isn't really addressing
their claim about the wisdom of a given approach.
>> I do think a lot of them also believe they already have
convinced voters and it's just like corporate Democrats and corporate
interest and evil things. I agree. Right. But then then it be
but but then it's like okay to the extent that they're making
that claim that is a descriptive claim which you have to address
and and say something like well no because XYZ look at these
analyses um you can see like the amount of money spent isn't
really influencing whatever you want to say. That's the thing
is if their claim is something like the smart strategy would
be no I don't know I'm not yell sorry my voice yeah it's a lot
of words exchange today. Um if the a strategy if the claim is
that Democrats >> non is just a small bean don't yell at
him come on Pisco what the [__] are you >> should
adopt a given strategy and this would be better for Democrats
>> [__] up >> saying like well >> moderates
aren't just going to hand it over isn't responsive to the claim
it
>> them can we can we put a pin on this for now because
we are going to do this way more and Pisco is not going to be
the the standin for the left we're going to have actual people
who have these very disagreeable positions >> I agree with
Hutch on this that's But that's what I'm saying. That's what
I'm saying is like you you're pretty much on our side.
>> Hutch says,
>> "Yeah, hold on. This ogre boy chat. Have you seen the
part where or have you played the part where Hutch says I'm going
to be on and his nipples start dancing?" No, I don't know what
you're talking about. And that is a insane sentence to write
ogre boy. So I'm very Do you have a clip? Because I think we
did play it and possibly
>> but I'm not totally sure.
>> If you have a clip of what you're talking about, I do
want to see that now. if whatever he's talking about, I do think
that would be hilarious to see. So, I agree with Hutch on this.
That's >> That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying
is like you're pretty much on our side in this uh debacle. So,
like it's it's almost like we're we're we're wasting all our
arguments against people that mostly agree with each other. >> Let
me Can I just say one thing real
Last thing. I just want the last word on this. Okay. It's the
framing that is just like poisoning the discourse. The framing
is that there's this monolithic democratic party that's like
a hive mind that make decisions through some some kind of collective
consciousness and that is not what is happening. We live in a
representative democracy. >> I don't even know what ghost
he's arguing with really I don't I'm trying to understand like
I can usually understand like like when he says flowchart left
us and familiar with what he's talking about when he's saying
people think there's a collective
cons a moderate consciousness. I don't I don't know what this
is referring to at all. Do you have any idea? >> Maybe
like the independents. It's probably referring to like independents
not wanting to vote Dem because they see the like far-lefty stuff
is totally toxic. Maybe that's what he's referring
>> the voters in the districts of the Democrats who voted
to pass that ICE bill, if they disapprove of those voters, they
can they can primary them and vote them out. So like the way
that you make decisions as a party is you forge consensus. And
that consensus is going to look different depending on what type
of candidates the voters themselves elect. So just stop treating
the party like a hive mind and start treating it like what it
is. It's a democratic institution. >> Well, that's I'm
sorry. >> I'm going to say the last thing now and I want
you to think about this for next week because ultimately it sounds
like at the end you're saying it's our their responsibility to
earn the votes and I feel like that's what they're going to fire
back at you when they don't vote for the general. But don't respond
to that yet.
argument. Exactly. >> Why? Why did Soy Pill say that and
he's like but also we're going to stop here. Why does he Why
does he throw the grenade at Hutch and he's like also pause just
let that grenade sit there. Okay, we're moving on to a different
topic. That's up. >> I opened this a few different times
and I think they had been talking about this for quite a minute
at this time and they're going to have Ogre Boy and Vim on next
week and I think he's saying save it for that. No,
>> maybe maybe he is. But I I don't know. I don't know
why you'd basically say, "Hey, Hutch, you forgot about the most
obvious thing." And then just move on. Hutch seems a little haunted
by this. Okay. He doesn't He doesn't want that. He doesn't want
that.
>> Hold that. I'm sorry. >> Well, you're saying,
you know,
Bernie didn't win because he didn't get the >> NO, PISCO.
THAT'S YOUR BOY, PISCO. You can't do him like that. That's your
boy,
>> Didn't follow that. I'm sorry. >> Well, you're
saying, you know,
Bernard didn't win because he didn't get the votes. I agree with
this. But it's like, okay, well, isn't it Kamla's duty to earn
the vote of the progressives who feel like they're disappointed?
>> It's her fault. >> It It is. I mean, sure, but
but like those voters who decided to vote for >> Oh my
god.
That it is from Hutch is like there's absolutely no other person
in this universe except for these people that could have extracted
that concession from him that easily. If I asked him that, I
feel like it would be like pulling teeth and he would never give
it to me that yeah, it's like fundamentally Kla Harris's fault.
I've heard him here say, and I don't even disagree with him on
this multiple times, it was Biden's fault more. And I would actually
say that's probably true,
but like I also don't think that if Harris had had more time
that she would have done any better. I actually think she probably
would have done worse given like where the trajectory of the
campaign ultimately ended up. So, I was like, if it was going
to be this, but for longer, I think she would have lost by an
even bigger margin.
yeah. I I think,
man, there's a lot of things to dislike about that campaign.
I think I thought she was doing a good job of like making her
own mark off the bat. I think
she eventually got reigned in by people. I right off the bat,
it seemed like she was going to go in her own direction. I think
she should have committed hard to keeping Lena Khan. And I think
she should have pivoted like further left personally
um on populist grounds. I I say further left. I think she should
have pivoted more populist.
He kind of leaned away from being more populist and I think it
hurt her. Um that's my opinion. I don't even need to say left.
I don't I don't even think like left was a requirement. She could
have like
the border.
>> What you just said people don't even conceive of it
as moving further left.
Like there was polling data that the New York Times cited. No,
there was like the majority of voters uh when they like I'll
have to see if I can't find it quickly, but there was a New York
Times oped that completely misconstrued some polling data that
they ended up having to retract with this op-ed saying that like
vote what voters want is moderate candidates or whatever, but
they were misreading the data. And voters actually perceive Kla
Harris as further left than like AOC and like some of the squad
members. And the reason being is because they perceive the being
like socially left, which they associated more with Kla Harris
than like AOC and the and the squad types that lean more into
like Medicare for all and increasing the minimum wage and like
focusing primarily on like affordability and cost of living as
like the centerpiece of their campaign and their rhetoric and
what they're constantly talking to their base about. Like
it's like that's what throws them to the left. So voters actually
don't see uh focusing on affordability, even if you're proposing
things like Medicare for all as like far-left.
>> This is Yeah, this is unironically why Camala was like
a death spiral candidate.
Um because of her Senate voting record that could always be weaponized
against her during like the most woke period of the Democratic
party. I just don't I don't understand why they went with her.
I mean, I I guess I get it that Biden probably promised he was
going to go with her or something, but like it was totally to
go with her. there's like the Japanese to go with her. >> She
really struggled in the primary. She was one of the first candidates
to drop out because she knew she wasn't going to get her home
state of California. The other reason why like she she was not
really like front and center during the Biden admin. Like she
was stuck with like affiliated with all of the most unpopular
decisions of the admin. She was like seen as the border the unofficial
borders are. We just talked about how Biden did not pull well
when it came to the border. Uh the Afghanistan withdrawal.
uh he emphasized that Kla Harris was the one to g to say that
this is how we ought to do this. Uh he said that multiple times.
It was reported by Politico when he did it. That was when his
polling numbers significantly decreased. They never recovered.
So she was affiliated with that foreign policy blender. Then
she was affiliated with all of the baggage from Gaza and the
existing foreign policy blenders that he was making. uh and just
on like she had flip-flopped on so many different things because
in 2020 when she ran she tried to occupy the progressive lane
then she tried to quickly moderate because she saw that she wasn't
going to be able to outflank Sanders on that and she also took
donor money so that was also going to make it more difficult
for her to do that. So she flip-flopped so many different times
that between the fact that she just lacks the charisma as a candidate,
she became very untrustworthy to voters very very quickly and
then again affiliated with all of the most unpopular decisions
of the Biden admin just a horrible idea all around. And it was
a big reason why Biden was actually didn't want to drop out and
why even Pelosi and other party elites that were pressuring Biden
behind the scenes before he ultimately did uh were kind of worried
because they weren't worried like just about oh what if we have
like can Biden make it to the general. It was like, well, can
Kamla if Kamla gets it? Like,
won't she lose even could she lose even worse than Biden is likely
going to >> and Obama both wanted a primary, right? They
basically I think Biden basically made it clear that it was like
no, it's Kamla. I think Obama and Pelosi both wanted a primary.
I think that was pretty obvious right off the bat that they were
like >> they did and then Biden
>> when Biden dropped out he immediately endorsed Harris
if I remember correctly in his statement and that apparently
pissed off Pelosi and the people that had pressured him because
he didn't want him to do that. They wanted there to be some sort
of convention.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
I remember that I
I famously advocated for um you need a white man. You just need
a a white man. Any white man, any white dude is all you need
right now cuz that that like one or two% of the electorate that
you need to flip are all going to basically be like like chuds
at heart and they're going to vote for a white dude.
And um >> that's where Tim Walls came in, right?
>> Yeah. They they picked the most feminine white dude
they could who had a history of like lying about his military
record apparently. But I don't know. I think >> such a
joke. It was such a joke. They were like bringing up the fact
that he misrepresented like he like exaggerated to the point
that he said he was like at Tianaan Square or something like
that uh back in the 80s, but it just like I remember watching
that first interview that he did, joint interview that he did
on CNN with Harris where they grilled him on that and I'm like
it's just so cute when you have like a literal convicted felon
running in opposition to these people and they're having to dig
up the fact that he had like a DUI 40 years ago and that he exaggerated
military tales.
I thought did those go to felonies? Those go to felonies. I don't
remember they went to he was indicted on different federal charges.
Yeah, it just it feels like it didn't happen because it didn't
matter in the end. So, I don't blame you. But yeah, he was indicted.
>> He was he was indicted.
But was he um Did they get convictions? I I thought it was I
wasn't sure if his felonies in New >> Yeah, his felony.
>> Yeah, he was convicted.
>> All right. Sure, sure. Sure. Okay.
Damn. Not sentenced. Yeah. What happened there that they didn't
sentence him to time? I thought he was almost guaranteed to get
like a little bit. >> I don't know if you know this, but
Donald Trump is a billionaire and was the former president of
the United
>> Well, I
do. You think that makes sense, though? I think that almost makes
sense if you're going to sentence him to like 6 months in jail.
I kind of feel like isn't it just way more hassle actually, unfortunately,
as it is, to house the former president in a jail, even if he
hadn't won. Like isn't it almost just more hassle to try to jail
this guy for 6 months versus like even if they're going to do
it later? I feel like they might almost just say, "Yeah, like
we're not jailing this guy for six months." It's [__]
>> It's like Trump that like what they end up doing is
like like Desh D Suza was like the one person that has gotten
in trouble for campaign finance regulations in this country like
violations in this country and he actually was like sentenced
and he had to go to jail and I think he only went on weekends
and he had to like sleep there overnight but then he was allowed
to just be on like house arrest or even like I don't even know
that he had that uh Monday through Friday for like 6 months.
If that if Trump were to ever served a day in jail, it would
have looked something like that. And because it's such a security
risk for him to be in like a gen pop of any prison or jail in
this country, there's no prison or jail for men like Trump. Uh
they would have it would have literally the security accommodations
alone. It would probably be like one of the most expensive
inmates to jail in this nation's history given all the accommodations
you'd have to make. And that would be even factoring in that
it would probably just be like a weekends only type thing.
Yeah, that's >> house arrest is fine. I would have settled
for house arrest. Yeah.
>> I'm not picky.
>> Um, Plantab wants to know, do you think there's a non-
evil there's such thing as a non-evil billionaire?
>> I mean, in the same way that there's like do you think
there's non-evil kings? It's not really about whether they're
like good or evil. It's that the role that they occupy in society
is like inherently dictatorial because of the amount of power
they have.
Yeah. What does evil mean is actually the question here. Gotta
get in some Jordan Peterson. Okay. I'm going to hit play on this.
I need to be right back. I'm going to fill up my water and I'm
going to get a drink. So, I'm going to hit play on this. But
I can pause. If you need me to pause, I'll be right
>> Decision. They
>> that's they are responsible. >> Or we're just
listening to them. Either >> Their decision. Kamla didn't
force them to not vote for her. They chose that. Do you do you
give do you give Kamla responsibility for not winning? It's not
failed to build a winning coalition. There's no doubt about that.
Kamla failed to win to build a winning >> We have a whole
show for this. Okay. All right. Do we talk about Greenland for
like 10 seconds? I I'm sure Non >> Yes, we should. I want
to hear Nvon's opinion on Greenland. >> All right. And
just to recap, Greenland. All right. I want to see more and says
that Greenland's a necessity. there's nothing that can happen
other than them capitulating to us. Uh completely threaten all
these tariffs and and potentially troops on the ground. Uh tank
all the markets and then uh declare victory when we get back
to the same place which is that they said we could put bases
there.
Is that did I get that right? Does >> funny that this has
basically fallen off the map? This was like the this was cute
when this was like the biggest issue facing like making headlines.
Trump's like attempted grab for Greenland and now it's just like
a total afterthought in light of all the ice >> Trump strategy.
That's the foreign
>> like I'm honestly not surprised like a lot of his trade
deals are like kind of scaled down versions of of that like you
know he'll announce some insane did with Colombia announcing
like some insane insane 50% tariffs on Colombia early on for
like literally no concession just because him announcing that
he got a deal can get like headlines it is not that surprising
to me. I am I am a little I there's a little part of me that's
upset that um we didn't get a some type of deal that like would
have given Greenland uh like citizens uh like a lump sum of money
or whatever. Um because that that would have
>> they're talking about Greenland is the I think it's
uh this is the end. >> They are talking about Greenland.
This is Yeah, the drama's over unfortunately. How long were they
on it before this? Cuz I feel like we came in and maybe we came
in too close to the end. I felt like we weren't that close to
the end, but maybe we came in too close to the >> Where
did you So, what was your starting
>> Um, it was some it was at some point they were already
talking about it, but I just went back to the place where Hutch
was asking a question cuz people came in and whenever they came
in, I rolled it back like 20 minutes.
>> So, I don't know. Do they start on it like right from
the beginning?
>> It seemed like it happened pretty early on to be honest.
Yeah.
>> Lykan is a dork and a friend. Why is How Lyan's getting
name dropped in this chat? I do not know.
>> Wait, my chat or your chat? >> No, on the live
and learn screen. You went to like a screen and I saw that L's
name was there.
>> Apparently, [snorts] >> because he was he was
arguing with Hutch on Twitter. >> Yeah, Rhinox just said
that Pisco was um
Pisco sorry. Ly was in Pisco's chat apparently talking.
>> Believe that this administration will ever be able to
>> uh I I saw the tweets. I looked at the tweets when you
mentioned it. I saw who he was fighting too.
Ask her what her starting point was. I have no idea. I Is that
a question? What was your starting point? I don't >> I
don't know. >> I don't know what that means.
>> It was sufficiently reform ice in this >> Wait,
did you see um do you follow any drama stuff? You followed any
of the stuff with Techone? Seen this?
>> I've followed a little bit of it. Why?
>> I was curious. I just thought it was crazy that um he's
been calling everybody a liar, saying they're slandering him,
and then the ruling comes out and the judge basically finds him
liable for the exact thing he said was slander. It's just poetic.
Very >> Yeah, this is very nice. I enjoyed it. I enjoyed
it a lot. A lot. Yeah, I enjoyed it a lot. We got to meet Msk.
Msk came. He chatted. >> He's in here together.
>> Yeah, he did. He was in the chat a couple nights ago.
>> Oh, wow. >> Show her Pinky Chew. I I I think I
told her about the meme. Yeah. This is um his girl his ex-girlfriend's
name is Pinky Chu and
>> I just have to remind people because they forget who
she is sometimes.
>> Oh, by the way, I opened something up before and it
was not that. I'm just going to open that again. Whoops. I opened
something before and it was not that. What was it? It was this.
What is
for the Twitter column apparently advertisement for the Twitter
community.
>> Okay. All right. I don't That's literally just the same
clip, but you say something about the Twitter community. Okay.
>> Jeez.
Yeah. If you guys go to x.com/jc
Okay. The general profile,
the Twitter community is now linked there. Okay. So, you can
join the Twitter community. Join up. Join the Twitter. >> Defense
Force. >> There you go. >> Defense Force. All right.
Is that all for the live and learn thing? I will bid you a do
if it is. >> I think I think that's it. I mean, hold on
one second
before you I was just going to message and then we'll see. I
one question and then depending
>> Yeah. Okay. All right. Yeah. Thanks for coming on. We'll
talk to you later. Hey.